okay for everybody that's here in the
room right now we're going to be
starting a few minutes later we have a
new side by side on HP uh SB 266 it's a
new one that's just been presented to us
uh representative cordelli's gone
upstairs tried to get a few more copies
made for the folks that are in the crowd
here so out in front not the crowd
but uh so we're gonna just hold off so
that when we start everybody can be
looking at the same document that we're
looking at
so just hang loose for about five
see Jennifer's not here she's in traffic
and so one of the other gals upstairs
gave this to me and she didn't know
okay I'd like to go ahead with the
the discussion we have today the work
session on SB 266 this enact relative to
Statewide educational Improvement and
assessment programs
and does everybody out front have a copy
of the 4 3 23
edition of this side by side
okay yeah
I went through the that looking at the
at least the placement of words on each
of these Pages it looks almost the same
as what we've had before so
um
we have uh from the Department here we
have
um Nate green and Caitlin Davis
uh what Nate and Kate and why don't you
come on up to the table so as we cruise
through this we have done some work on
this
um Caitlin were you here for that work
yeah we did yeah
okay so perhaps what be wise for us to
do here so as we go through we've
identified to where we dropped off some
issues or not issues but where it didn't
match up with current law and so what we
can do is probably ask some of those
questions of Caitlyn and of Nate right
now so maybe we can get some answer to
that
so I can start out
on page three
there was question on the on the left
hand side there at top what we're
talking about academic standards
and above that let's see
um
okay yeah the academic standards the
academic standards this is written in
law means what a student should know and
be able to do in a course or at each
grade level when we looked at on the
other side for academic standards we're
also seeing that it's now Statewide
academic standards or academic standards
and any mention of of a course is gone
or four
perfect yeah
um
so academic standards as a whole is a
much broader term that encompasses
everything that a student might do at a
grade level some of the standards in
particular subject areas cover larger
standards that may not be specific to a
particular course so if we're
referencing courses specifically they're
going to be Niche level courses at the
high school level that may not
necessarily have course standards but
they would have larger sets of Standards
attached to them a good example of this
might be if you're a senior and you're
taking an English elective in a
Shakespeare literature there may not be
specific core standards relatively grade
so having the requirement that all
courses have those standards they're not
necessarily course level standards most
of the time we have grade level
standards and then often our larger
courses have core standards that come
from the grade level standards so on
follow-up to that and I'll let others
join in
we have social studies and we know those
standards are adopted in the latter part
of 2008 something like that and those
are applicable not just to Elementary or
middle but they're also applicable
and if we're talking U.S history there
are academic standards for U.S history
that's a course that's required for
graduation at the high school
it's not a grade level somebody might
take that at grade 10 some might take it
at Grade 9 11
Etc so so that's the reason why we had
in statute the word course there because
it's grade levels up to a certain point
but then it becomes coarse
and that makes sense I don't think that
there's a large issue with having the
word course within the definition I
don't think it presents a problem to the
field to have it within that definition
so I think if that's something that the
committee wanted to add back in I don't
see anything we're not wanting to add it
back in it's inside right so I'm sorry
okay uh are there other questions that
what is the difference then between
Statewide academic standards and
academic standards
so Statewide academic standards would
refer specifically to any standards that
have been adopted by the state board of
education but we know there are a lot of
other standards out there Beyond just
what have been adopted by the state
board so academic standards refer to any
set of academic standards that a school
and District might use Statewide
academic standards are specifically
yes representative
uh thank you for taking my question yeah
so does this mean then uh based upon
what you just said that the uh that the
uh state board will uh adopt Statewide
Savage so the state board has adopted
Statewide standards in the core content
areas for the state so we have statewide
standards in English mathematics and
science we have a social studies
framework that I believe the State Board
had adopted a number of years ago I know
that there's been talk about updating
those but beyond those four core content
areas I don't believe the state board
has adopted any additional standards so
for example in art or music there aren't
Statewide standards that have been
formally adopted by the State Board of
Education
and so uh what is to what extent then
will school districts Charter Schools
Etc be except be expected to adhere to
those standards so right now most
schools and districts in the state use
those Statewide standards but there
isn't a requirement in statute that all
schools must use those standards the
reason most schools use them anyway is
because we use those standards to create
the state test and all of the students
whether you're in a public school or
Charter Public School are required to
take the state test and so if a school
is using a different set of Standards
than what we've built our state test on
they may see differences in the academic
performance of their students so so then
the local school district or Charter
School it's up to them whether or not
they want to adhere to those standards
at their Peril if you may correct from a
standpoint of
aligning with the
Statewide exams in yes yeah and in fact
the there is a statute because the state
board when they adopted the New
Hampshire framework for mathematics and
for ELA those were the Common Core State
Standards we have another statute that
says explicitly no District shall be
forced to adopt the common core
standards
representative Ford
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
this may be the English probably coming
out when you hear my question but I'm
concerned about what is the intended
meaning when you say means what a
student should know and be able to do in
a course and at each grade level now as
a former English teacher I'd like to
delude myself perhaps by thinking they
knew less when they entered the course
and emerged with more so I just want to
clarify that's what the current law says
that is the language that the current
law uses so if we have issues with that
we could talk about that but we were
trying to not stray too much from that
how do you determine what they need in
order to take the course from what they
need to graduate from the course
so the standards are the expectations of
the knowledge the students will have at
the end of the course okay and primarily
we use this to set our benchmarks on the
state test so when you have fourth
graders take the fourth grade State
assessment that's based off of those
fourth grade standards and see
expectation that by the time you get to
the end of fourth grade you'll have met
those fourth grade standards so if we
revise this to read upon completion of
it would be a little more explicit
it would yeah one of the things that um
we've had conversations with schools and
districts about is the particular
testing window because the standards are
based upon what the students will know
by the time they get to the end of that
grade level depending on when students
take the test if it's towards the end of
the school year or if it's a little bit
more earlier in the spring they may not
have gotten through all the different
standards so there is some scheduling
considerations when schools are looking
at their curriculum and what they're
teaching and when they're giving the
state test to make sure that students
have mastered those standards for the
grade level am I correct in assuming
that that could skew your data
um
yes theoretically it could we haven't
done any kind of research into different
schools and when they're testing and
whether they're we see differences at
that level between schools but
theoretically it could if you had one
school that tested much much earlier in
the spring and one school that tested
you know far later and the end of the
school year
thank you
further questions on this represent
Tanner and then representative cascaden
thank you thank you um how is you talked
about common core but how is Esa sa
affected by this
so one of the things we've done with
this particular draft in their Visions
is to bring it in line with the current
Essa regulations
um and so regulations require states to
have standards that's one of the reasons
why the state board has adopted the
standards that we have because in order
to have uh State assessment system that
will meet the Essa regulations it has to
be built on those nationally recognized
standards not necessarily Common Core
but the state has to adopt something to
use as a framework for their state
testing
yes
so Essa I believe also had social
studies and some other subjects that
that were under Essa
um
is that not taken into consideration now
or so there isn't a requirement that the
state test in social studies so right
now we're meeting the the requirements
of the SSA states can then add on
additional requirements and most often
that social studies one is the next one
that adds on and there are many states
that do have State Testing programs and
social studies but that's not something
that New Hampshire has had as part of
our Statewide testing program
thank you
representative cascadden
um I'm just questioning
um
academic standards that that particular
line and I know you didn't want to go
there but
does it relate to the 193e colon 3 the
delivery of an adequate education I mean
can we say that
the Statewide standards or academic
standards of schools use
to show what students know and be able
to do at grade levels is the delivery of
an adequate education
it's not necessarily no because
the delivery of inadequate education has
the two different parts so 183 e3b is
the accountability section and that
talks about the performance-based
accountability system and that's based
upon a number of factors some of that is
achievement and growth which is based on
the State Testing system so in that
sense it does pull in those academic
standards because that's what we use to
build the state assessment and then
measure students achievement and growth
but there are a number of other factors
that are taken in as well as part of 193
e3b additional data that goes beyond the
State Testing system
thank you
to me Nate it seems like the tail is
wagging the dog here in this we're we're
basing our academic standards on a
Statewide assessment test
not on our curriculum that we have those
other components of a substantive
education which they're what nine or so
subject areas there but we're only going
to be measure our accounting or for
improvement and assessment on English
language arts math science
um reading that's it and what about
areas that are not uh tested like health
for physical education or music or
personal finance literacy how do we
measure those academic standards and why
why then are we not saying those are
academic standards
that are
you know I'm just getting really you
know I think we're trying to align what
we do as standards with our assessment
rather than the assessment lining with
our curriculum and our instruction so
right now the assessment aligns with the
standards that we have for science math
and English and teachers build their
curriculum off of that so I would I
would say in essence that those three
subject areas there is a pretty large
alignment we have the standards I'm not
questioning that alignment so I would
say the the biggest issue with not
testing and all those other subject
areas would be cost and budget so we we
do assess in those three core content
areas and our Assessment program you
know is is four to five million dollars
a year to be able to assess in those
three subject areas to have a valid
Statewide test that all students take
requires a pretty large resource with
personnel and time and and finances so
it certainly is you know something the
legislature could look into if it's
something the state wanted to go in that
direction but we would need
significantly more resources to be able
to test outside of those three core
I'm not trying to say we have to do a
Statewide assessment for those core
areas I'm trying to
say that the academic standards for the
non-tested areas are just as important
as the ones where
we're we're testing for
so
um I'll I'll leave it at that and our
measurement of that right now is through
the ibass system that that's how we
okay is there any further disc yes
represent Cascade
just based on your what you were saying
it made me think that all districts at
one point I believe when Essa
um came on a table had to develop
competencies for everything that was
taught and I had to develop a system
either through ibas or pbas to measure
how the students met that competency
so I don't know if there's a need for a
national or Statewide testing
for that
I mean is that I mean that's what I'm
thinking just well I can remember when
we went into the business of
competencies and I can remember Fred
bermonte being here and working with us
on that and the concern we had back then
and while some are just going to take
their goals and objectives and those are
now our standards uh and uh some school
districts probably did do that initially
but those competencies are based upon
thank you so schools and districts
um write competencies at the local level
we do have some State model competencies
in some areas that districts can use but
but they are a model they're not a full
set of competencies and competencies
really are part of the local curriculum
so one of the issues you run into in
trying to look at it from a state level
and do comparisons across schools and
districts is that everybody has written
their own set of competencies for the
most part and that makes it a little bit
harder to then do comparisons not only
from one school to another school next
to it but across all schools throughout
the state because we don't have a set of
standard competencies in every
curricular area it really is a part of
the local school curriculum so schools
and districts if particularly if you
have a large District so for example if
you're Manchester or Nashua you would
have a core set of competencies for your
District that all of your schools are
using so they have a good way of
measuring whether students are
proficient at their local level but it
does make it challenging at a state
level to compare schools to each other
because again not everybody's using the
yes I I get that part representative
cascaden thank you
um yes I mean I definitely agree with
you Nate um you know and I know there
are teams and regions that have worked
together on competencies because it was
an overwhelming task to begin with
but would it not change a definition of
adequate education if there was more
testing
or am I not asking the right question
are they the same as adequate education
and because there's a lot of discussion
of what's an adequate education and it's
very clearly defined but now where
Statewide testing is just in the three
Three core areas per se
and if we were testing more
of the requirements in the Ed rules
would that then transition back into
adequacy which you know has a ripple
effect
I mean do you see a correlation between
what's defined as an adequate education
and what requirements and Statewide
testing
if there is a connection
so that's a hard question there's I
would say there there's a connection to
link it yeah there is a connection in
that the way we've determined a part of
our accountability system does rest on
the assessment system the accountability
system is also much broader than that
and looks at many other factors things
like graduation rate attendance data
School environment data so we take a lot
of that into account with the
accountability system
you could reinvent or reimagine I think
the way you look at inadequate education
by saying we're going to look at it
purely through an academic lens and test
in each of those required areas but
historically that's not something that's
ever been part of our current statutory
system the testing is just one component
in the the pbas system in 193 3B
could you have a follow-up yeah just uh
one more follow-up and you can have them
um so is the accountability system
and so there's a couple of components to
it so ibas for example looks at all of
the requirements in an adequate
education so schools have to verify that
they're in compliance with all you know
12 or 13 of those areas and 193 e2a and
that's on the front end that you know
you have a arch program you have a
mathematics program you have a world
languages program you have a school year
that's 180 days or 990 hours so that's
also part of the accountability and that
looks at each of those areas in e2a the
assessment part is on the back end in
terms of the output so how are students
doing in particular areas things like
their math achievement or English
achievement How are schools doing with
their graduation rate and that's where
we the assessment component fits into
that part of it but I think you have to
look at the totality of both ibas and
pbas together to verify whether students
are providing or whether schools are
providing the opportunity for an
adequate education
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for uh
both for being here if I can get away
with it I might have a couple questions
here
um so in the first couple pages I see as
far as developing the test it refers to
people involved including stakeholders
and among others it specifically
mentions Community Representatives I was
hoping that you might be able to provide
us with a fairly comprehensive view of
who would be represented by stakeholders
and exactly what is meant by Community
Representatives
so I probably wouldn't be able to give
you a specific example of you know who
would be represented as a community
stakeholder at what point they've been
involved in that process when we go
through the development of the State
Testing
um much of what we do
that pull stakeholders in directly is
the standard setting oftentimes that
involves local school leaders and
teachers in each of the grade levels and
the content areas so when we set the cut
scores for our state testing those have
all been done by groups of New Hampshire
Educators that have come in they've gone
through the test questions they've taken
the tests themselves and identified
based off of their classroom knowledge
and instruction and curriculum if a
student were to take the test and answer
questions at a particular level this is
where those levels will be on the state
test so as we're measuring whether
students are proficient or not
proficient much of that has been done
through those committees we also have
committees that come in and look at
things like bias insensitivity reviews
we go through particular items to make
sure that the items themselves make
sense and often that's done through
Committees of stakeholders that we bring
into the department
thank you for that
um and if I may
um as far as the particular items that
are to be tested as far as various
competent competencies go I see a number
of references to things uh such as
social competencies or preparing uh
students for social engagement so is
there supposed to be measurement or
testing for any sort of non-academic
competencies such as social or emotional
competencies in this there's not now
actually if you could point me to a
reference because the tests themselves
each item on the test is directly
connected to a particular academic
standard whether it be math or Ela so we
don't have any social emotional
standards that the test itself is based
on sure yeah I was just looking at
things like page five line 29 for
instance successful participation in the
social economic scientific technological
and political systems of a free
government and other references like
that there wasn't anything specific to
that so I just wanted to rule it out
okay yeah so this that's part of sort of
the overarching I think purpose of why
should a test uh or why should a state
have an assessment system what do we
hope to get out of education for our
students so it's not that our assessment
system necessarily measures everything
within that list I think that's sort of
an idealistic overarching statement of
why we do education yeah thank you and
if I'm if I may again on page four
um line 29 through 30.
um it says that the department May
collect and uh shall provide
uh student address information to the
third party testing what is the need for
collecting their home address that was
that was added in about two years ago to
ensure that the student assessment
results were provided directly to
parents so there was some concern I
think um it was coming from this
committee you might remember
representative lakis that parents
weren't able to access student
assessment results so that's what that
legislation was added for
what I I think we ought to do is rather
than jumping around through here let's
continue going in in order through this
report we're on page three in my last
part in common here is I'm really
concerned that we're relegating all
those subject learning areas which are
not tested to the back seat of the car
in fact we had testimony the other day
when we had folks in here testing or
testifying on the Civics bill
and basically as social studies they're
saying well that you know it's not being
taught in some schools not because we're
not tested on that in these schools
um so it is a concern to me that the
academic standards should be based upon
all those areas
that we have called adequacy and aligned
with those competencies at various
levels and at courses so that we
unfortunately you know one of the
persons that testified was a credible
person with the Education
Association and indicated that she's not
too sure that the only thing that's
being taught in fact of New Hampshire
history might be the visit to the
um so
it's not it's not tested anywhere so
and we're we're putting a lot of heat on
teachers to make sure you do an adequate
job and the way it's discerned by the
public is that assessment test this the
federal test which we're required to
give
and so it seems to me the federal
government's wagging what we do here in
New Hampshire so I think there's
probably some room for improvement on
our Assessment program and all the
additional areas but that's a large
departure from where the current law
lies and that's not what we're trying to
do with this bill
um and again Nate just talked about it
would take a large amount of resources
to do this additional work we're able to
leverage our federal dollars right now
to do a lot of the work that we're
supposed to do for the state side of
things through the federal dollars
because it's a basically a two-for-one
deal we've already required to do it
from the federal side of things so we
just kind of get the benefit on the
state side of things if we're talking
about developing a state Assessment
program that has a large departure from
the federal program we should talk about
what that looks like potentially maybe
have a study committee over the summer
talk about you know have additional
resources from schools assessment
vendors and whatnot
um and that's certainly some place we
would certainly be able to provide
support to the committee on doing that
but that's not the what we are in 10
mentioned what this bill was yeah I I
get that and you know I can remember
when we used to have social studies as
an area which was part of the
responsibility of the state to test we
weren't doing it so that's why if
economics geography civics government
history were all put on to the local
level uh I I probably wasn't there that
time going ahead and doing that and I
can remember representative Heath saying
be careful where you're going and that's
exactly where we are right now we're at
the point where
um it's it's you know we don't know
what's going on in terms curriculum in
that area curriculum we know
performance why on that one test how
they're doing in those areas which are
tested but
a lot of emphasis was being placed on
testing and that's kind of governing and
the dollars needed yes I understand that
you get federal dollars you have we
appropriate dollars for the testing
but if that should not be I guess we're
building a budget or a budget that's
what we're building we're it's not
program budgeting it's Budget Building
you know where in other words the the
program is not you know dictating these
costs it's what we have we're building a
program around the budget
kind of kind of reverse philosophy that
I was taught when I was in school
but I guess it's reality
further questions represent Tanner
so I guess
banking on what you've been saying a
little bit is that I'd like as we go
through this and and particularly with
this one you said it wasn't the intent
and I'd like to know
um with these changes what's the intent
of it why are you doing it and also what
are the potential consequences on the
over because part of the problem with me
looking at these statutes is and you
know they're also intertwined
particularly around adequacy that that
if we change one part how does it change
another part and what's the consequences
on a local school district so if you
could give some information background
information on that
um I too am very concerned about the
academic standards that that we get down
to the point where
um as we were the last term where uh
school ends up being science math and
English and that's that's it
um and you know a comprehensive
education takes in much more than that
so uh if you could kind of talk about
changing the academic standards as you
have here and I don't exactly know why
they're in quotes
um
but what what's the intent of that and
what are the possible consequences as
far as an adequate education and
comprehensive education so they're well
to start with simple simplest answer the
reason that's in quotes is because this
is the definition sections of the law
um and we use so that's why that's in
quotes
um and so currently in current law we do
already have a definition of academic
standards
um the reason we use Statewide academic
standards and added that word Statewide
is because there's confusion right now
of are we talking about local standards
are we talking about state standards are
we talking about the minimum standards
the word standards is used so many times
throughout the law to talk about
different sections that we've we kind of
just thought additional narrative as an
additional descriptor there would help
clarify which standards we're talking
about here even after there was a an
oversight Committee in this room a month
or two ago and Nate was here I know we
were talking about all the different
standards and the differences of
standards and competencies and all of
those things and we were talking about
that we actually probably need to write
a paper on from the Department fine when
we're talking about academic standards
when we're talking about curriculum when
we're talking about competencies and all
of those right now I think there's
sometimes they're conflated and it's
confusion and and so what we've tried to
do and the majority of this is is just
us going and saying like add additional
descriptor add additional word here so
we know exactly which section we're
talking about I mean you'll see that a
lot more and when we start getting into
rsa193e if we ever get to that section
of the spell
um
and I
uh we are prepared to do exactly what
you just said throughout this document
and that's what we've done many times
now
um having this this document that Jen
prepared is fabulous because it's really
helpful for that
um so as far as
far as the impact on the local level we
don't anticipate any local level because
this is on our current practices this is
what we currently do we're just adding
that in
um I do since we're on a definition
section
um I think we could add in the word
adopted by the State Board of Education
to add further clarification and um or
we can add in or the course level back
in that language just to help
um with the committee's concern with
that I don't I don't think there's any
um issue with adding that back in great
okay let's keep moving on
um are there any other questions on that
page page three
yes represent Belcher thank you Mr chair
thank you again I just wanted to look
real quickly at line 32 that
which which
the apology is all I'll hold for later
okay so anything else on page three
representing
thank you Mr chair thank you take my
question
um
this occurs in in several different
places so it's a question not only
specific to here
where a particular RSA is replaced with
the words under this section it's not
because we well why is that and why
wouldn't we specify the RSA
um we did that because some of these
were disjointed in different rsas right
now so now we've we've combined them all
into the same section so you can refer
to it under the section and if we say
under the section it just kind of helps
us with or helps actually OLS as far as
not having to go in and renumber each
section every single time you make a
little change or add a different size so
um we felt as long as it's defined and
contained within this section it was
that was the appropriate kind of
legislative drafting so
um I do just since you're um the
superintendents had asked or had
requested that we add a definition of
transcripts because it is referred to on
page nine
um so we talk about the Statewide
assessment results of schools or
students
um shall not be included in a school
students transcripts
um so we will add we would like to add a
definition on their requests and so do
you have that designed yet or
um if not could you get that to us yeah
okay anything else on on that page three
superintendents right down in the middle
of the page there's a section says other
open-ended performance tasks and you
know looking back at this assessment
process
and uh the Senate version here is other
items
types identified by the department and
testing entity as necessary to
appropriate measure to appropriately
other item types is that specific to
what
so other item types would be inclusive
of any other item type so we would be
able to develop with the testing vendor
that would appropriately measure student
learning so it's a more inclusive way of
including different ways of including
items on a test that we may not have
thought of yet I think when when testing
first began you know over 100 years ago
testing was primarily multiple choice
educational research has come quite a
ways in the last hundred years from you
know the original intelligence and IQ
tests that were developed that were
primarily multiple choice and especially
now that we're doing more things with
computers we have computer adaptive
testing it opens up different ways of
creating item Types on our tests so this
is just making sure that our statute is
flexible enough that as we create better
or further questions yes representative
Tanner thank you are we still able to
use the performance-based assessments
so the performance-based assessments
that was part of the PACE program was
discontinued that was done under the
iada waiver the state may seek an
additional Ida waiver in the future
depending on what types of innovative
assessment strategies we might come up
with as an alternative to the
traditional State Testing but currently
we're not using pace
did that go through uh the legislative
action when the pace was removed
it's so right now I think language that
had allowed the PACE program to operate
is in the current statute we've modified
it a little bit to make sure that this
still continues to remain open so if we
do a program like Pace in the future the
was it was the discontinuation of the
PACE program done through legislative
action no it was not it was part of the
federal program it was primarily funded
through federal grants that we the state
no longer received
so this so the state department decided
that they were not getting funded in so
they were not going to continue the
program we weren't able to continue the
program correct thank you
well we had a waiver for that from the
federal government didn't we we didn't
space yeah we had a waiver but in
addition to the waiver we had an
Innovative grant that allowed us to fund
the program and the department was not
receiving that Grant anymore
represent cascadden
so that
the pace districts is how what initiated
performance-based assessment
but yet we don't have pace of the
support to the districts but we continue
with having performance-based assessment
so we have the option to have
performance-based item types as part of
yes representative McDonald thank you
um moving downwards on the page it says
shall be clearly defined before
assessment procedures and that's in
current law and that language is removed
from this bill as amended so is that
altering the timeline or are standards
going to be developed before the
assessment takes place or can I
interpret this as standards a develops
based on the test results so the
standards are the standards that were
adopted by the state board and depending
on the tests that we're looking at there
are different times so for example the
science standard for the Next Generation
science standards those were adopted in
the 2017-18 school year so all of our
science Testing since then has been
based off of that so that's the language
where it says we have to have standards
first is because we build the test off
of the standards that teachers are using
so down the road if the state were to
change those standards we'd have to
build a new test based off those new
standards all right thank you
okay are there any other questions
regarding page four
yeah that's represent Damon
thank you
I don't completely understand your
answer to representative McDonald's
question can you just revisit that
uh sequencing of developing the
assessment procedures
sure so the the first thing that you
have to do before you can build the test
is you have to know what it is that
you're testing and so that's where the
standards come into play so with science
we use the Next Generation science
standards it's a very long comprehensive
document I used to be a high school
science teacher I've not read the full
document but I've read that portions
that were specific to what I taught
which was chemistry and physics but
essentially the standards outline what
every student should be able to know and
do at the end of a particular grade
level or course so for example what
should first graders be able to do in
science at the end of first grade second
grade third grade and so on in science
we test at the end of fifth grade eighth
grade and then we test our 11th graders
so the science test is only given three
times throughout a student's academic
career and the science test is based
upon the set of Standards leading up to
that particular grade level so fifth
grade science tests would include
science content that students should
have learned by the end of their fifth
grade year and that all comes from those
stand standards
so follow-up so in the excuse me change
it doesn't seem to me that it's saying
um
I'll just stop it I appreciate it for
the further questions on that yes
represent Myler
thank you uh on a
you've changed the uh word into in
consultation with Educators and
stakeholders
does that mean that it hasn't been
happening in the past are you just
trying to codify the practice so so I
had I think me and I were just talking
about this I think
we were trying to clarify this in this
section and then I think we went back in
and added a definition to Statewide
academic standards so I think we could
probably stop this it said it says a
Statewide academic standards get rid of
the rest of that language and
potentially
um just make sure that we're clarifying
that definition back on that scene that
first page because there was areas that
we were going through we were writing
this and they're like well I think just
having a definition so we can refer to
this throughout it because we use the
word standards again on the next page
um I I think so if we were just just
stop it right at standards and then get
rid of everything else I think we're all
set I'm I'm not in this agreement with
the current language you've proposed
because I do think the issue of
Consulting with people who are going to
be implementing this should be part of
this language because I'm assuming the
department is it does not want to go on
and do it unilaterally without including
those who are actually going to be
dealing with these standards so so I'm
I'm in support of what you currently
have in here I just had a question about
what in consultation means
and that's one question secondly Define
who the stakeholders are
because one of the one of the concerns I
have is whether or not in the
stakeholders I'm assuming you're talking
about parents Etc are students involved
in that
because students bring to the
schoolhouse store a much higher level of
understanding of what their needs are
Etc and I think they're often it's often
overlooked and and we as adults try to
say well here's what you need to have
which is important no question about
that but they also have some sense of
perspective too so that so the question
I really have sorry uh the question the
question I have is really what does in
consultation mean and secondly how do
you define the question of stakeholders
so we haven't done this process in a
number of years because it all the the
process of Consulting with the
stakeholders and Gathering feedback and
buying comes when you first adopt those
standards so if we go back to the 1718
year when we adopted the science
standards there was probably about a
year and a half long process that led up
to the State Board adopting those
standards and I want to say there was
anywhere between maybe about eight or
ten different dates that were a
listening session around the state where
Department Representatives had gone out
and set up a day you know in a school or
in a district or in a community center
where they had parents and students and
teachers and community members come in
and ask questions about the standards
and provide feedback so it was a fairly
lengthy process that occurred leading up
to that adoption we could certainly
codify that as a particular process but
it included I would say probably about a
year of public feedback yeah and again I
just want to be clear I I appreciate
that in consultation section because I
think that's what you have done
according to what you were just saying
and I think it needs and needs to be
codified here so that the there's no and
there's no impression here that the
department is just is developing this
stuff in thin air and then say okay you
guys have to do this now so I I
right represent Tanner
um
yeah that I I guess the my question here
is the cut scores uh standardized cut
scores
um and I'm not familiar with that term
is it I know that proficiency one of the
one of the things I'm finding with the
public is that they don't understand
really what's the word proficiency what
is behind the word proficiency uh they
think proficiency is the same as passing
and it certainly is higher than passing
so um
could you tell me what cut scores
standardized cut scores are and uh is it
something to do with setting the level
of proficiency it is yeah so those two
items go hand in hand the way that we
report out student performance on the
assessment is through proficiency and
it's a scale
so students fall within one of four
categories they are either below
proficient approaching proficient
proficient or above proficient and each
of those
categories is set by a range of scores
on the test so when we refer to
standardized cut scores it's the
particular score on the test where a
student would need to meet that
particular cut score to go into that
next level of proficiency so if a
student is in a category that's below
proficient there would be a cut score on
the test where as that student passed
that score they would move into the next
category of proficiency
yes
I think uh publicly it should be made
more
apparent what proficiency is that it's
it's really like a b b plus you know I
mean
part of it is we've all gone to school
and we've gone ABCD and now we see
proficient and as I said out in the
public people don't understand what
proficient is and one of the things that
we're starting to do with the test we're
working on more and better communication
out to parents specifically parents and
students and in understanding the
assessment data and the assessment
scores one of the things that sometimes
a little bit challenging and trying to
communicate the general definition of
proficiency is you could have two
students that both have a proficient
score on the particular test but they
have different strengths and weaknesses
so they're proficient in say fifth grade
math but one student may have different
strengths and different weaknesses and
if they still fall within the same range
of scores and so that's where we're
trying to provide more detailed
information about what it is that
students are really good at what is it
that they're a little bit more weak on
what do they need to work on and a lot
of the information is in the
individualized score reports that go out
to parents and then one of the things
we're working on now as well is trying
to take those score reports and create a
video format that we can provide to
parents that's more explanatory of what
is on the assessment and how did your
particular student do what did they
really excel at and what is it that they
can continue to work on
mm-hmm
so I I don't think
I think what we're doing on on uh giving
information to parents and continuing to
improve that and the information is to
teachers is very vital but where it
comes back at us is with the public and
when you say you know 20 only 30 percent
of students are reading at the
proficient level on something in in New
Hampshire as a whole or in x y and z
school
um that doesn't give a full picture to
the public uh because they don't
understand uh what proficient is but
that's another day I think to remember
you that you're concerned I think what
we can do is propose a definition of
okay representative you can then
representative Cass Academy thanks very
much
um Mr chair
um just sort of a follow-up to um uh to
representative Tanner's questions
um regarding cut scores at a um
at an ncsl chairs meeting that I was at
last October
um they reported out that New Hampshire
is in the process of proposing to raise
the cut scores I'm actually reading from
a slide raise the cut scores used to uh
award a school a score from one to four
for the academic achievement and other
academic indicators and I was wondering
um where we stand in terms of that
proposal right now
so that that's a little bit different
than the standardized cut scores on the
test so those are not changing those
have all been set by the standard
setting that we did a number of years
ago with teachers what we did propose
this past year was modifying the the
limits at which we're identifying the
schools that are the lowest performing
schools in the state and that uses a
range of different indicators one of
which is academic achievement we have a
federal requirement that we have to
identify no less than five percent of
the lowest performing schools in the
state and the current cut scores we were
using did not identify five percent it
was actually below that and so we by
using the scores we currently had we
couldn't identify five percent so we
were out of compliance with federal
statute so what we did was we looked at
the performance of schools across the
state and tried to identify about where
would performance be if we had to
identify that five percent and we moved
our indicator scores up to that point it
was a small change but it brought us
back into compliance with federal
statute it did not in any way affect
student performance or the scores that
students had received to be proficient
okay so I'm going to follow up on that
if I made so so
in those cases
that that cut line that five percent cut
line is to and and um the the
um the the term is is evading me right
now CSI CSI yes not a CSI cut line yes
it is okay thank you
representative cascadden you had your
hand up
um yes just to add a little bit to what
representative Tanner was saying at
least five years ago
um schools transitioned their report
cards sort of speaker they're reporting
to parents in the proficiency levels
with the explanation so that some some
schools do quarters still most
elementary schools do trimesters now
but all that explanation of proficiency
is has been provided at least for the
five the past five years but I
understand that the public looks at the
negative part but I'm wondering if that
public are those parents who weren't
informed enough of the levels of
proficiency because
they have it if they have kids in public
school
so I I'm just trying to sort through as
a public school system not educating
their parents enough on it but levels of
proficiency has been a reporting
mechanism for at least five years
multiple times a year
to those parents so I don't I know
that's there
[Laughter]
ready to move on to the next page
because some of this is kind of re you
know repeat itself again two pages later
you're gonna see the word consultation
again appear up and there'll be more
discussion on that so yes representative
Woodcock thank you uh they think just a
clarification orange sure I think I must
have heard it wrong did you say that the
we had a level of cut scores that
identified the lowest five percent
performing schools but because we
couldn't identify private scent we
increased the cut scores we can meet the
federal language we have that many
failing
yeah so when we initially created that
first cut score is when we first moved
from New York Child Left Behind to Essa
and so there wasn't really a good sense
of what our data was going to look like
so we didn't know where to set the cut
score so the cut score was set on
theoretically what would identify five
percent of schools three years from the
date the cut score was set and when we
got to that date it turns out we picked
the wrong number so it truly was it
wasn't that that number was based off of
anything hard it was sort of a
subjective number and we knew down the
road most likely we would have to vary
the number a little bit to make sure
that we were capturing the schools that
need the most support one of the things
we want to make sure that we do is
really specifically identify those
schools that are within that bottom five
percent because there's some significant
Federal funding that then goes out to
those schools and so
that the funding is really attached to
making sure that we're providing the
most support to the schools that need it
the most
hey thank you Mr chair so how are you
doing in the high school when I don't
know if the SAT or the ACT is part of
this equation here because you're
talking about again grade level
expectations
um are you giving a PSAT prior to the
sat in the 10th grade and then the sat
in the 11th and and is that part of the
statement because in the previous
academic standard specified what
students should no one be able to do
shall be clearly defined before
assessment procedures and exercises are
developed
is the SAT giving back what we're trying
to find out or are we doing that in
terms of seeing if these kids are
prepared for the first year of college
so there's four indicators at the high
school level that all factor into the
formula for identifying high schools for
that bottom five percent the SAT would
be one component so we look at academic
achievement and that would be on the
reading math and Essay sections of the
SAT we also look at graduation rate so a
school that has a very low graduation
rate could also be and end up being
identified within that five percent
because that's one factor we look at we
look at the performance of our English
language Learners on the access test and
we look to see how many of those
students are approaching proficiency
with English at the high school level
and then we also have a number of
College and Career ready factors that we
look at I believe there's 11
there's 11 factors and so by the time a
student has reached the end of their
senior Year we're looking to see how
many of those students have met two out
of those 11 factors they include things
like taking a dual and concurrent
enrollment course earning a certain
score on an AP test earning a certain
score on the ASVAB test so there's a
variety of those indicators that uh task
force a number of years came up with
before the set of students are doing two
or more of those items they're more
likely to be College and Career ready
than a student who hasn't met anything
on the list
those four indicators all together uh
there's a formula we put together to
identify what are the high schools in
the state that need the most support
because they have the lowest scores
across those four indicators
thank you yes represent Luna just to
follow up on what well you just asked
here because I think I think that I
think I'll just speak for myself I just
heard some very important information
that sort of connects the relationship
between well those are the delivery
indicators of an adequate education
right right but it's not and it cuts and
it goes all the way down to the student
outcome proficiency scores in the CSI
cut scores and uh clearly all of these
things are are linked all the way back
to through to assessment and academic
standards and adequacy
hmm
and and I I was I was wondering if it
might make sense and we don't have to
get it today because you've just given
us a little bit of verbal on it but a
maybe a short
um
report or summary of of how these things
are are connected because it's going to
be really
um I think as we go through and evaluate
the academic standards it's important to
to recognize how it all trickles back to
um through assessment and student
outcome Cuts proficiency cut scores and
yeah I you know I'm following what
you're saying but I'm again concerned
that the indicators which we're talking
about come at the end of a student's
traveling through High School they're at
the end graduation rates as a CTE dual
concurrent enrollment those are not
going to be giving us information like
the Statewide assessment that you're
talking about gives individual student
information back as well we're talking
about aggregate stuff at the end for a
high school so it doesn't in terms turn
around and say this is what we have to
do to try to better ourselves in
10th grade ninth grade or any other
grade it just says overall your schools
has a crummy graduation right here this
are a wonderful graduation rate
and that's and that's that's School
related that school specific data not
student-specific data that's right but
it does relate to I think you know the C
you know an indicator for the for the
CSI it does yeah so those pieces taken
together that that represents the
performance-based accountability so that
pbath so when we were talking about 193
3B that's the accountability for an
opportunity for an adequate education
the criteria for CSI or TSI or ATS
schools that is our performance-based
accountability system and the data that
goes along with that
um and I so I know that this is a very
short kind of verbal explanation about
this um but I will call out one of my
colleagues here
um kirian Guang who works uh within our
Bureau has created a set of uh 12 videos
sort of an accountability 101 on our
system
um that we could make available to this
committee as well that we've put out on
the website for school leaders to who
also have similar questions that want to
understand the accountability system
better
but that sat doesn't get proficiency one
two three or four levels so it doesn't
give us that information about a student
it does so because we because we use the
SAT for our Statewide assessment we went
through the same standard setting
process with our high school teachers
and we identified different ranges of
scores on the SAT that would correlate
to proficiency at the junior level of
high school so depending on what a
student scores on the SAT they will
still fall into a bucket of being below
proficient approaching proficient or
above proficient wouldn't it be more
useful than if we did it off the PSAT in
the 10th grade so we can use some data
to help us get those kids through grades
11 and 12. many students do take the
PSAT within schools a lot of districts
offer that as preparation for leading up
to the SAT to do that at a state level
again would just be an additional
Financial cost that we would have to
I know it I mean we give it a ninth
grade but it does I mean the district
has to pop buy it yeah
okay one brief follow-up sure one that
bit of data thank you for taking my
question one bit of data that I haven't
heard mentioned is any correlation
between teacher preparation and student
performance it seems to me that we're
not looking at the full picture if we're
not also considering that
I think in particular the fact that
English language Learners are often
taught by people who themselves have
never been required to learn another
language
we we had a a pretty good discussion on
this with the higher education committee
the other day on Friday
we went all morning on that topic so
let's just jump over it right now and
and Coach page five is there anything on
so yeah so we're in the assessment
section
um so we removed this because it's
already referred to in the adequacy
section and we didn't need to find in
both sections so adequacy refers back to
the third grade reading assessment and
we don't need that here so
foreign
getting rid of the third grade funding
and adequacy so it was not done in
correlation with that that happened it
also happens to be being proposed in a
budget simultaneously but we just said
we were trying to remove duplicative
language
what about page seven
I think there's some questions here
um in the in the first one where it says
rule making
the state board and education that was
in rules shall adopt rules this one says
may adopt rules why did you change it to
me we changed it because we don't
currently have assessment rules and we
are functioning well we believe
um so we wanted to make that a May in
case we did think we needed that
clarification further but we don't
currently have rules and don't feel that
well I congratulate you on that one we
don't need any more rules we agree okay
um areas of assessment
this is where we knocked out history
geography civics economics Etc
from the Statewide assessment years ago
I'm not prepared to yeah I don't think
it's a change here we literally just
combined the two we added an and and
then so we just it just reads together
as one sentence rather than two
sentences
well they they are different
there's a huge difference between the
first sentence and the second sentence
one's local school
one Statewide assessment dealing with
the reading language arts mathematics
and science
the history all that so that's where we
are right now I understand that
um
I guess my my biggest concerns on this
page are on the bottom section there
and that that is where we had Pace
before or a norm reference assessment
which could be used by a district in
consultation with the department and
that would be considered part of the
Statewide Assessment program So
currently um the process of the
department follows for that is a process
that we do that in consultation with the
U.S Department of Education
um so right now the current law just
talks about that we're allowed to do
that but it doesn't actually refer to
the process being a process that needs
to be enabled by the US Department of
Education even though that has been the
process that was approved and used for
the pace process so all we did was
clarify that it was if a process is
offered by the U.S Department of
Education and so there is currently
language right now in the essel law that
enables the school district to do this
but if they reauthorize us into
something else five or six years ago
from now and they remove that language
we won't be able to have that Authority
so that's kind of we just add some Flex
disability we didn't feel that this
changed the current process at all
um it just felt like it just kind of
explained what we were currently doing
yes representative so so with the
removal of this language
uh will uh school districts still be
allowed to uh do their own assessment
so in order for a school district to do
their own assessment it has to be
approved through a waiver process and
that's the clarification we made here so
districts can't just on their own go out
and do their own locally developed
assessment in place of the state
assessment if they were doing that they
would be in violation of many of the
requirements of our title programs that
would not be able to continue to receive
federal funding as a school so that's
the the clarification here is yes
schools can do an alternative Innovative
assessment if it's approved through the
department of the U.S Department of
Education
so
it has to be approved through the U.S
department not through the state
department our state department so
generally the process is and this is
what we did with pace is we wrote a plan
out uh for how we were going to do pace
and then we submitted that to the US
Department of Education and they
approved a waiver that allowed the pace
districts to administer the pace
assessment as an alternative to the
state assessment and we need that waiver
process because schools are required to
participate in the state assessment
process in exchange for receiving title
dollars and so if a school outside of
that waiver process were to create their
own test and stop using the state
assessment they would not be able to
continue to receive that Federal funding
that they received through the title
programs do they do they receive that
waiver by going through you as a conduit
yes to get that waiver it's our
department that submits the waiver yes
thank you
I would just suggest that you have
language in there that says it's through
a waiver process just to clarify it
um
and schools again can still do
Performance Based assessments if they go
through the waiver process with the U.S
but we don't do pace
so it would be it would be the New
Hampshire Department of Education I
would have to submit that waiver right
so we currently do not have a waiver in
place to be okay so the department
would determine whether that goes to the
federal level or not yes yeah and
generally we look to our stakeholder
groups things like the state
accountability task force to determine
you know are we going to submit a waiver
what might that look like what could a
program be
um there's a lot of I think discussion
with the field initially when we began
pace so what that's going to look like
how schools will implement it and the
structure of the particular waiver that
yes representative Woodcock and then
representing
on the uh on the last block and going
back to that that line it says if such a
program is offered by the department so
did I understand you just say that that
means if you already have a waiver uh in
the department already so what that
means yes so they couldn't create
the department create a new waiver
request by a local school district or to
have three summons already in place
so we could one of the requirements when
we initially did Pace was that we had to
show not only you know was it a viable
alternative to the state assessment but
it was something that could be scaled up
and eventually become Statewide and so
you couldn't put something into place at
only one school district would do you
would have to show through that waiver
process that it's something that would
be scalable in the state and that
multiple districts would want to take
advantage of that that was one of the
challenges with the the PACE program is
we had a ceiling in terms of the number
of districts that wanted to participate
in the program as an alternative to the
state assessment
represent Damon
thank you
so if I'm reading this correctly
there is a significant reduction in the
amount of assessment because the current
law has three grade levels where
assessment happens and the draft
language has just two is that correct
so we wanted to clarify because it did
seem like it was a little bit vague in
the original statute so right now we
administer the state assessment in
grades three through eight and then once
in the junior year for Math and Ela and
then science is grades 5 8 and 11. so
science specifically is just three
grades and that follows the federal
requirements so those are grades we're
required to assess students in
oh yep
so in the original language when it says
once in an elementary school grade once
in a middle school grade and one grade
in high school that is not what is
happening is that what you just told me
that is correct
and so what's in the new languages what
is currently happening yes not a
reduction in practice correct yeah so
this is one of the changes we made to
bring our current state statute in line
with current practice it may be that
some of this language in the current
statute was a holdover from No Child
Left Behind where assessment
requirements from the feds may have been
a little bit different than it is now
with Essa but currently we assess in all
those grades three through eight and
that's a requirement of our federal
Assessment program
so we weren't in violation necessarily
State Statute we were just the federal
law was more expansive than what was in
our current state statute and we wanted
to align those two together with this
change
thank you this this is a real departure
from what we I I remember writing this
section myself with Gene Chandler
and
it gives the opportunity to a local
school district we want to use a
different assessment we'll consult with
the department so we'll be part of the
Statewide Assessment program but we're
going to move ahead and use the Iowa
Test basic skills Stanford we're going
to use California achievement whatever
test they want to do and and yes they
may not receive federal dollars they may
not want the federal dollars
but this this allows them to just do
this very thing
and the way it is right now they can
only do it if it's offered by the
department and approved by the United
States Department of Education so this
was a real effort on the part to really
go to local control
in terms of this assessment instrument
now that's being taken away
it will no longer you know if you're
using some other assessment in your
school that will no longer be an
assessment you can use if you're not
using the Statewide assessment
so
yes I think the way that to your point
the way that was originally written a
school could say we're not going to use
the state test we're not going to go
through the waiver process we're just
going to use say that Iowa Test of Basic
Skills uh we understand we're not going
to receive federal funds we're not going
to take the federal funds
um so they and that would be all across
all their title programs so title one
two four the other issue with that
though is that we would lose data on
that particular school because our state
assessment system we've gone through and
done some pretty rigorous standard
setting over the course of of multiple
years in terms of constructing these
tests we don't have any of that data on
any of these other assessments so we
wouldn't know what particular scores on
those assessments equate to proficiency
or not proficiency we wouldn't have a
way of getting the scores from those
other tests districts are using through
our current data portals so we wouldn't
have any way of reporting out the data
so essentially those schools would kind
of almost become like little black holes
of data within the state and we wouldn't
be able to compare them across any other
schools in the state because they'd be
using different assessments
see the background on this was back when
we're doing smarter balanced building
and when Common Core came in effect
there were some districts very upset
over having to so the the up their Annie
they went beyond the standards and then
wanted to go the direction of their own
that's when Pace came into play
um so it seems to me we're just kind of
moving away from that concept
um and everybody's going to have to do
the same thing the other thing that was
in it so
sorry no go ahead representative
no
um
since the department doesn't support
Pace districts any longer do you still
have districts in the state or do you
have any idea how many we'll use a p-bat
pbas system
so all schools are required to use the
pbas system and that's based off of all
the different indicators within the Essa
plan
um so it's not based off of uh Pace when
we had Pace districts their scores were
equated with the state assessment scores
um and that was one of the reasons why
it became challenging to continue to use
Pace when the Federal grant went away
because there was a significant chunk of
money that we had to pay to a vendor to
be able to take the pace scores do a
statistical analysis of those scores and
equate them to the scores of students
taking the regular assessment so that
they could all be reported together and
you could compare a pay school to a
Traditional School using the traditional
assessments without those dollars
without the ability to do all that
statistical analysis we weren't able to
we would have had to run two different
accountability systems and the
accountability law within State Statute
still requires schools to meet all the
different state accountability
requirements which are currently based
off of our state assessment so there's a
question there of what would
accountability look like for a school
that might be using a different system
we were able to build a lot of that with
Pace using the money that we had without
having a pretty significant investment
of money it's very difficult to do
comparisons of multiple assessment and
accountability systems
but yet schools need to do both
input-based and Performance Based now
where at one point they had a choice
they did have a choice I think it was up
until 2019 and it was changed and so now
that they have to do the
performance-based accountability system
which is aligned to this assessment if
we didn't have a way to compare them
they automatically would fail pbas in
theory or they would have to be exempt
which there's no ability to exempt to
school right now from the
performance-based accountability system
and so we would not be able to measure
them and and then ensure that they're
I think we need to pause for a moment
here we viewed the term pace
throughout this morning in my sense as
members of this committee have no idea
what you're even talking about
um so could you so could you please
could you please define the PACE program
why it was done because I think we've
used it several times this morning and I
think it's very relevant to the
conversation we're having here thank you
yeah so uh pace is an acronym it stood
for performance assessment of Competency
education and the PACE program was a
specific program that used
performance-based Assessments in place
of the state assessment
performance-based assessments require a
student to be engaged in a more real
world type problem that may require them
to create or to think critically about a
particular situation and answer multiple
questions involved with a particular
performance task it's a little bit more
involved than a traditional say multiple
choice test so there is a difference in
the type of assessment it also requires
more
um
work on the part of teachers because
you're grading that performance
assessment through the use of rubrics
and coming up with a score that you can
then use for accountability
um it was run for a number of years we
had a number of pace districts that were
using those performance tasks in place
Department let me just clarify so the
department had um received the waiver we
were talking from the U.S Department of
Education to use this in place of our
our traditional State assessment system
so as we went through the whole process
of applying to the US Department of
Education receiving that later process
we'd also received some large grants I
believe was you know multi-million
dollar grants from Nelly May and a few
other National Partners I was funded
this program and as over time you know
we didn't have the funding to continue
this program and it kind of just
expressed some of the kind of the
challenges of that we could no longer
implement the program so now the
department discontinued Pace but is
still implementing a Statewide
assessment which is just our regular
Statewide assessment in the grades three
through eight and eleven it's called the
Hampshire SAS if I may and just to
clarify so students would then have to
demonstrate that they they they can
perform the competency or demonstrate
the competency is a bit different than
just marking a an exam of a multiple
choice it was a much deeper level of
understanding of whatever the topic
might be that they were studying and I
think at the time it really became a
model for the nation as it relates to
these competency-based education so I
just thank you for the clarification I
think people Now understand a little bit
more represent Lucas
is there a reason we can't just have the
whole
so we're not having to compare two
systems just that sounds like a much
better system to me
it's much more expensive
okay
even if you're not trying to compare
the two systems if you're just using
that it's still more expensive because
why the costs are not associated the the
higher costs not the cost of using both
systems it was the the cost of
implementing the system in general
um so it's part yeah part of the reason
so the the state assessment is
administered through
um computers it's digital it's adaptive
so as students move through the
assessment depending on how they're
answering questions on that state test
the test is automatically going to
either give them more challenging or
slightly easier questions as the test
identifies where the student's
proficiency lies and that's once you've
built the test it's really just kind of
maintaining that system and keeping it
going with performance-based tasks you
have to generate new performance tasks
for students at every grade level every
year and you have to train all the
teachers who are going to be
administering those so the training
requirements of being able to work with
those teachers train them develop the
items and then do all the grading
because you have to have multiple
teachers individually great paid those
items after the students completed them
the time commitment to the resources and
the training was significantly larger
than the state assessment system and
that was one of the reasons why I became
challenging to get more districts to buy
into it because of the time commitment
and the training commitment on their
teachers without so we were paying
teachers additional money to do the
training to do the scoring to be
involved in that
thank you
further questions on on this page
on the last uh at the bottom of page
eight there's a Roman five it says
Department shall provide the testing
entity with individual pupil names and
unique pupil identifiers
and other student demographic
or statistical information what what do
you mean by other
sure so one of the reasons that we've
added that in is the assessment vendor
that we use for this at the end of every
year when they go through the data they
do a lot of statistical analysis for us
to make sure that the test is valid and
reliable and one of the things that they
do for many of the other states but not
for New Hampshire is they look to see
how are students performing on
individual test questions based upon
their demographics so for example if
we're looking at free and reduced lunch
students you know students in our lower
socioeconomic groups how are they
performing across each of the different
questions that students in those groups
are seeing but because our vendor
doesn't have that kind of demographic
information they can't provide us with
that level of analysis on the exam and
that's something that they do for all of
the other states that use our test New
Hampshire is the only one that we're not
able to receive some of that information
we've worked with U.S Department of
Education on this it is a requirement of
peer review for State exams you provide
that level of statistical analysis what
we've done in the past is we've provided
the U.S Department of Education with
information from other states that also
use this test but unfortunately that's
just a best guess as to how those groups
in New Hampshire would be performing
because we don't have that analysis so I
think providing this information would
just it gives us another level of
looking at the test and making sure the
test is really performing the way that
we want it to and that students are
performing across all the different
questions that we've built into the test
representative cordelli
uh thank you I don't have it in front of
me but several years ago we revised
language in terms of what data we could
provide the testing entity
and we mentioned address earlier but I
don't recall anything being put into
statute about providing this other
demographic data related to those
students can you help me with that
so that that would be a new change is
providing those additional demographic
variables so that the testing vendor is
not necessarily going to be looking at
individual students they're looking to
see groups of students so you know on
particular questions if you have a
question that performs well in one
particular subgroup of students but
performs poorly in another subgroup of
students that's information that's
helpful for the Department to know why
is it that on these particular test
questions one particular subgroup of
students is performing poorly
it could be that there's something that
we're missing with that subgroup of
students from an instructional
perspective but it could also mean that
that test question itself is written in
a way that is biased towards a
particular group of students and so that
may not be a question that we include on
future versions of the test so it's a
way for us to make sure that the test
continues to remain high quality year to
year and it provides us good information
instructionally to then provide out to
districts and teachers
represent miler all right I want to uh
thank you
I want to address the s.a.t and the ACT
prior to having this become the High
School exam
we had received reports from actually
students and uh teachers that this
particular exam taken in the 10th grade
or the 11th grade whichever it happens
to be was kind of a joke
didn't take it seriously so the
reliability
of the results of that data was fairly
suspect
this committee as well as this
legislature made a decision to go with
the SAT and the ACT
for a couple reasons
one it would allow a standardized test
that was a more serious frankly than the
one that they were taking before
secondly it provide an incentive for
students who are taking this that scored
better than they thought they would that
would say well maybe I should go to
college
so and the feedback that I've gotten
from superintendents and teachers Etc
that this is a very serious exam that
that they now take a much different way
than it was in the past that it is
successful
so my question to you is why would we
change that
the second the other issue is when it
says select one or more vendors
how is that going to provide some sense
of standardization across the exam field
if you may
so the question is why would you want to
change this at this point in time other
than it may provide some cost to the
department so
um you may remember the original Bill
back in 2015 or whatever I want to put
that said the department shall use sat
that was the language of the department
requested the legislature did not accept
the word shall and put the word May in
there so the current law the department
may use the college board or sat as an
assessment vendor the department still
may do this this language right here
doesn't enable or require the department
to do anything we are still enabled to
use sat through our state Contracting
process but we so all we're doing is we
we shall essentially select vendors one
of which may be the SAT the department
is actually proposing right now an
additional five-year contract extension
with sat to continue to administer that
at the 11th grade level
the additional vendors so we do
currently have multiple vendors through
our assessment process so right now we
have a third grade third grade um an
English language learner assessment
which is a vendor called Wida we have a
assessment vendor called Dynamic
learning Maps which is a special
education vendor we have cambium which
implements New Hampshire SAS which
previously we used Smarter Balance which
is the three through eight assessment
and then sat which is the assessment in
the 11th grade so we already have
additional vendors so we would still use
the same vendor for the same measurement
so if we were assessing third grade
reading across the state we would have
maybe one vendor that does that so right
now that's SAS also luckily enough we
have the same vendor that does the third
grade math test which is and they also
the New Hampshire SAS which is cambium
but we so we would still use the same
measurement across across the state for
the same subgroups but we would have
potentially different vendors and we
would still potentially use sat so all
we're doing is referring to the state
Contracting process essentially
requiring the department to do an RFP go
to governor and Council all of the
process would be existing we currently
follow but we're getting rid of the
specific reference to college board
because the current language does not
actually require the department to do
anything well it may not require it but
it has been doing it and there was at
the time we did this is call there was a
rumored to be a suspected vendor that
had a particular bias that was very
troubling to this committee and so you
can understand my suspicion
of why this is being changed because
frankly I notwithstanding what you're
saying Caitlyn about the ability but the
history of the essay I'm specifically
looking at the SAT has been so
successful that that I I really
questioned taking that as an alternative
out of it so understanding what you're
saying about your five-year commitment
Etc well and I agree but if we
Department wanted to change our
assessment right now we could because it
says may it doesn't say Xiao it says we
we may use that or we may use whatever
vendor you're talking about under that
current under the current law we
actually felt that by referring to the
state Contracting process and
specifically putting in this year so now
now need to go to governor and Council
that actually strengthened the process
and took probably more freedom away from
the Department to specify that we we
must go through the Contracting process
but we can use whatever vendors right
now that we want to based on this law
this law doesn't anytime there's a May
it's we may do it we may not do it
hmm
represent luno thank you very much Mr
chair
um
looking at this um you know this this
paragraph here on on page eight and and
obviously that follows
where where
um 193 C colon six started on page seven
and um and it talks about on page seven
where School District may choose to
participate in a locally developed
alternative assessment program
uh in place of the Statewide assessment
I'm wondering if maybe to uh to satisfy
representative myler's concern here that
we expand that to be
um
Public Schools may use the act or sat to
satisfy the Statewide assessment and
that's you know in the event that the um
that the department chooses a different
assessment or maybe depending upon how
the department is is Led chooses an
assessment that that that really goes
goes maybe
um you know against the the educational
programming at most of our Public
Schools so at least it would give our
Public Schools both chartered public
schools and school districts the ability
to to continue to use the s.a.t and act
um would that be some and and be
consistent with what's being done right
now what's being taught in schools and
and consistent with the the ability for
schools to select their own
assessment test
so one of the that could be one
possibility absolutely we've looked at a
couple of different
um you know different ways of drafting
this or language because you know as
Caitlyn mentioned you know we are
getting great data from the SAT we're in
the middle of signing on with a you know
in the negotiations for another
five-year contract you know so that
would put the SAT for the next five
years as well as the assessment that
we're using regardless of the language
here in the statute uh we could add some
additional definitions as well around
the type of assessment that is there are
definitions for different types of
Assessments that come directly from the
federal Essa law one of those is a
nationally recognized High School
academic assessment which is an
assessment of high school students
Knowledge and Skills administered in
multiple States and recognized by
institutions of higher education in
those or other states for the purposes
of entrance or placement into courses in
post-secondary education or training
programs and so the SAT would fit that
definition so
having that definition in there means
that we want to select an assessment at
that level that meets this definition
and the SAT meets that definition there
may be other assessments that other
states may use it may not meet that
definition but this comes right from the
federal Essa law
and so that could be another way of
putting it in there that no matter what
assessment we use it's got to meet this
particular Federal definition which we
know the SAT does
representative McDonald did you have
your hand up earlier
I was just continuing along the same
line of reasoning relating to the SAT or
act from what was stated it doesn't seem
like changing the language would really
change the practice so I'm just
wondering if removing SAT and ACT from
the statute if that's part of a larger
discussion to really move away from
these tests we've had testimony on other
bills relating to student mental health
and knowing that these standardized
tests in particular the SAT is a huge
source of anxiety for students I'm
curious of the reasoning for this is
related to that as well
not necessarily no so one of the reasons
why we wanted to pull specific reference
to a vendor out is because a
relationship between a state and a
vendor does go both ways and so while we
want to use the SAT as a Statewide
assessment it also means that college
board has to do specific things on their
end for us through that contract that
they don't have to do for students that
are just administering the SAT
there's a whole data relationship right
there as well as peer review peer review
is a year to two year long process of
reviewing an assessment statistically by
the state by their Vendor by U.S
Department of Education to make sure
that that assessment meets the federal
requirements for a state assessment
college board down the road could decide
that's more work than we necessarily
want to do we're not going to do that
and if we have specific statutes that
are calling out a vendor even if we may
want to use them if it's not if they
decide they're not now going to meet
that definition it would be a difficult
position that we would be in to try to
use a vendor that now doesn't meet a
particular definition because of vendors
being called out in our state statute
now we don't exp that's a hypothetical
right we don't expect that to occur we
have a great relationship with all of
our vendors and again as Caitlyn said
we're working on that contract now with
sat we think we get really good data
from the SAT it's just in our minds in
terms of any relationship with any
vendor it's always safe to not
specifically call out a vendor name
within the statute because you don't
know what's going to happen five years
now or 10 years or 15 years down the
road so crafting a state statute that
ensures a particular type of assessment
as opposed to calling out a specific
vendor name just provides the department
a little bit more flexibility but we're
not looking to change anything in terms
of our current practice with this change
representative cascadden
um I was just I agree with you I mean
vendor names really should not be in
in statute
but we have so much
um
faith in the s.a.t
that you could and it makes me nervous
not having any reference to that in
particular to the high school level and
I just wondered if you would consider
that sentence on the left the department
may you may use doesn't say shall use
for high school assessment and add that
to your new section four
I think that if if the committee has
that much faith in the SAT
you should change the law to a shell but
it does nothing the way it is right now
so if you if if you're saying that what
New Hampshire wants to do going forward
in perpetuity is use sat change it till
the department shall use sat and then we
don't even need to deal with all the RFP
process and all of that that comes with
it so I like that idea there you go
but yeah when we initially looked at the
ACT versus the SAT we had Consultants
from both organizations here testifying
and providing us information there were
are there still students in the state
taking the ACT there as soon as it take
act it's just not used as a state
assessment in the 11th grade and that's
all we're talking about right now as
we're talking about the one common
metric that the state is using for
accountability purposes for state and
federal accountability purposes and
ensuring that that schools are providing
adequate education what that measure is
right now is being measured through the
SAT
um school kids take SATs many times we
know that kids take PSATs take take the
ACT but the metric that we are using for
our state and federal accountability
purposes is the SAT
further on this page yes represent
cordiello okay so this is regards also
to the SAT and I do think it's good that
you've changed it so you don't mention a
specific vendor
what I question is the possibility of
the College Board
being a vendor
because
um
I question the validity of the SAT as a
a
good indicator
for evaluating the public schools
many many students take tutoring courses
because even though a lot of colleges no
longer require the SAT it's still
something that you know when with some
of these competitive schools
that you want to do well on
and so there's many students who take
these courses and
so I wouldn't that skew a little bit so
that what if you use that as an
assessment for the public schools
it's kind of bringing in to the equation
the the use of
resources outside the public schools
such as these tutoring
I don't think we'd be able to get away
from tutoring I think we see tutoring
for many students across a lot of
different areas um I know I've used
tutoring services for some of my own
kids when they've come home with a bad
report card in seventh grade and we
thought we've gotta get a math tutor for
Maddie let's get that going
um the SAT is changing the format of
their assessment a little bit as well I
think they've started to shift to doing
this assessment for more States as an
accountability measure the SED
historically has been paper-based it's
been a single form every student has
taken the same sat they're now moving
more towards an assessment style that
matches our current state assessment
which is adaptive so now it's more based
on the students performance on each
individual question so students go in
and take a question they may receive a
slightly more challenging question or
slightly easier question depending on
how students are performing on that on
pieces of the SAT so I do think the
assessment itself is Shifting and
finding ways of really actually
measuring student Proficiency in those
particular areas that's right I think
there's always going to be you know some
students that have different advantages
because they've accessed tutoring
opportunities after school opportunities
things like that and we know there are a
lot of opportunities geared towards sat
and the act because of their role in in
college placement
in the in the many high schools give
those
SAT prep type classes
um
so they're available to every kid in the
school
represent cordelli yes just in relation
to the tutoring the department has a
contract currently so tutoring is
available through tutor.com at no cost
to every student and I believe that does
include some s.a.t related instruction
with their tutoring service it does but
it also may include tutoring for a third
grader that needs reading assistant
exactly so right yes
any further comments on this page
representative Lucas
um I'm going back to the section 5
discussion and I'm wondering if you can
be more specific about what other
student demographic or statistical
information is I mean you mentioned free
and reduced lunch but what all
are you collecting
so this would be the primary subgroups
that we report out on so that would
include things like free reduced lunch
uh students with disabilities
the ethnic and uh racial groups that we
collect information on
um and uh puts the to another oh yeah we
have some smaller group of military
connected students in foster care as
well as English language Learners so
those are sort of the primary groups so
for example with that demographic
information we'd be able to compare how
students with disabilities did on
components of the test versus general
education population or how did the free
reduced population students do in
comparison with say students with
disabilities or the general education
population it gives us another measure
to make sure that our test is a valid
and reliable test for all of our
students in the state
thank you
represent Myler you can correct me if
I'm wrong here isn't the SAT that we're
currently providing for our high school
students it's not the same
it doesn't cover everything that's
available for example I appear that it
doesn't have the writing component in it
for example there so there are it's not
the totality of if I was going to just
take this by myself getting ready to go
to school but am I correct in that it is
the same it concludes writing it does
include writing yes so so it is the same
it is okay okay thank you for that
clarification and it was something that
we made sure to add it because I know
that early on when we first talked about
adopting the sat there was a discussion
around would it just be you know the
reading and math sections or will we
include that writing and that is part of
the Statewide contract that we have
we did when we had to do that and we
held us an important benefit for all
students in the state to have equal
access to the SAT and and that included
if you know you need the writing portion
for college entry you that didn't we
wanted to make sure that the kids that
were taking that as part of the 11th
grade assessment that was the only time
they were taking that test
um they weren't being excluded from that
so
representative Woodcock thank you
chairman
um as regards the other groups that you
just identified the subgroups
um
would that data be available to schools
individual schools so they could improve
their instruction what would it be just
uh for the Statewide analysis event so
that data is is currently available to
schools because schools already have the
demographic information and so when they
You Know download their assessment data
into their student Information Systems
they can look across their own student
demographics because they have that this
would be more done at an internal state
level not necessarily for any kind of
external reporting because we do some
external reporting on subgroups already
this is really just for when internally
my staff are looking at the assessment
and looking at that data is the
assessment doing what the vendor is
telling us it should be doing so it's
really not for public reporting thank
you thank you sir
Santana
thank you so
um I guess the my question is around
again the shall select one or more
vendors through Statewide Contracting
process
um so the selection is is basically uh
process that the Contracting process I
assume is with rfps and and goes through
the executive Council that sort of thing
but um so when you uh propose these
vendors who actually
um what what process is used to select
them and then the fact that you say one
or more vendors does that mean that
schools will have a choice
of what what they'll be able to do where
you have like two or let's say two or
three vendors that um you know one
school wants to do a classical education
so they're going to take that particular
vendor and another school is going to be
a school that really focuses on college
prep and so they want that's that vendor
so it doesn't give schools a choice it
but we have to provide different types
of tests as part of our state assessment
requirements so for example the SAT only
looks at Reading Writing and Mathematics
it does not include science in the SAT
so we have a second vendor cambium that
provides a science test for our Juniors
so when 11th graders take the test they
take the SAT for the reading and the
math but then they also take a science
portion that's provided by our other
vendor cambium so we talk about one or
more vendors it's to make sure that
we're satisfying all the different
requirements and not every vendor does
every test the dlm is another great
example they provide a test for students
that have severe cognitive disabilities
that can't take any of the other
assessment instruments that we have and
so those are assessments that are geared
specifically and scaffolded in a way to
provide instructional information for
those students that we wouldn't be able
to get that kind of information on the
other assessment systems
okay let's let's move on I'd like to get
through 193 seed for lunch and then we
can do ee later
um
which is another couple page anything on
I think this page just has stuff that
you know the number of kids which you
have to have 11 or more before you're
going to
it's the number of kids taking the test
before you get some kind of information
and if you only have two kids three kids
in a school
pretty easy to find out who they were
protecting information
so that's been one of my my interesting
things was to to try to see uh you know
the test results of some of the smaller
number of schools and uh you know when
one or two people take the SATs or or
something like that that's it it really
isn't very uh telling about what the
school is doing so
is there any indication that if if a
school because parents can opt their
kids out
um
uh and they get a minimum size of less
than 11 is there anything that the state
department does to or to try to
encourage or help that school or come
and talk to the parents about why it's
important to take the testing so that
more students are involved that I have
had many and my staff have had many
conversations with superintendents and
principals around parent opt-outs and
providing additional information if we
can directly to schools or districts or
helping School Leaders with elements of
that communication out to their
Community
um under state law right now parents
can't opt out and they have that ability
to do so so it definitely does affect
our data reporting it can affect it in
many different ways but it's not
necessarily something that schools can
prevent parents from doing either
because state law currently does give
them that right to opt out
represent cordelli thank you I just
point out that uh
um Roman 4 in current law
is changed up above
um
similar to questions about the test and
entity and student provided data on the
previous page that I I think we need to
look look at closely as a committee if
we're going to make those changes I
think we kind of felt that eight might
have been an arbitrary number and we
wanted to just say like weirdly what
should that be is there a time where we
may need to have more flexibility around
that especially if there were we have
had many conversations about a
kindergarten assessment and things like
that but we wanted to make sure that
there was a very clear path forward to
having a destruction policy in place and
so we thought that would be better
determined in our a contract with the
vendors versus that right my only
concern is handing over to the
department the termination of that
if you don't mind so I think the
department would also if that were to
stay here we need clarification around
what does eight years mean is it eight
years from Individual Student Records is
it eight years from a particular
contract is it eight years based off of
a grade that was tested because that
changes the records that are going to be
destroyed and so to say just eight years
is not specific enough for us to be able
to communicate to that vendor what is
eight years mean
so if you are to do something in
accordance with the new language
proposed here what would be your
timeline you know as determined by the
state contract what would you try to
negotiate to get in as far as the
turnaround of information all right
destroying it I think we would look to
see what are some exemplary examples of
student data privacy and records
retention destruction rules that are out
there there may be examples already
within the state possibly in other
departments or even in other programs
within our department but we don't have
something specifically proposed here I
think we were looking for just the
ability to have a little bit more
clarity if we could put together an
actual data retention schedule with
requirements around Data Destruction
than what's currently in law because
eight years was one possibly arbitrary
until it's a little bit too vague to
have a really robust data privacy record
destruction schedule
okay good yes representative Tanner just
thank you just on a follow-up where
you've eliminated down at the bottom of
the page a school district shall not
become I assume be penalized any
Exempted student nor shall they
uh Department of Education or State
Board of Education penalize any school
district for a lower lower participation
rate you've taken that out so this is an
area that we actually wanted to have a
discussion with the committee on um
because we actually right now the way
that the federal law works is we are
required to essentially have a penalty
for students that are opted out
federally if a student opts out of the
assessment that's required to assess
that score is counted as a zero so then
that if school had a high number of
students that were opting out the school
would have lower scores that were being
used for the purpose of accountability
that's required federally we don't have
the ability to do anything about that
if we have a state accountability system
maybe we want to talk about for the
state accountability system that they're
selling maybe not any penalties but we
don't have any flexibility around the
federal side of things
so we were bringing that forward as a
discussion point because
technically right now we are penalizing
those schools because of that
so so you're saying that in the state
reporting
to the feds you can penalize they want
you to penalize us for non-participation
correct
so if you if you report it that way to
the feds that's how you're reporting it
to statewide right now we're not
delineating it for a state state
purposes we could potentially do that
but at this point you are actually going
against the current law and you are
penalizing because we are acquired by
the federal law to do so
great
representative Cascade and then
representative Belcher
so does that reference
um when you have to penalize say a
student just for a matter of
conversation isn't there a threshold
that
in the requirement that each school has
to have at least uh 95 percent
participation rate correct so anybody
within that five percent
is that what the feds say you have to
yes yeah so no no
yes
95 threshold so
the I mean the state law right now we
could match it exactly with what the
federal law says we could I I don't
really we didn't really know what
direction to go in right now because we
need to implement the federal law and
the state law so and what's that
threshold of participation the state law
has well this this is the state law it
just says the state shall not penalize
that anybody but because we haven't been
traditionally running State
accountability
um we need to talk about what we should
be doing for State accountability so
right now we have this issue where the
state and federal law contradict each
other the Department's a little confused
in which direction to go and we're kind
of previous discussion before and we
knew the 95 level yeah so that's why we
wrote it in the way it is there are some
schools at that time dealing with the
instrument we were using there were
questions
I think at the time when we wrote this
in um this was prior to the
authorization of Essa which specifically
required school districts or the
Department of Education to count those
scores as a zero before there was just a
kind of a question if a school didn't
meet the 95 they may lose any or all of
of federal funding so that was kind of
always the conversation that had been
had
um and then when U.S department
education reauthorized Essa that's when
they came in and they said all right
don't take your federal funding away but
count those scores as a zero to kind of
have that metric be the same across all
districts or old schools rather oh yes
so is the federal
um level at 95 participation yes okay
and the state did not adopt the same
percentage no this there's no percentage
in the state law okay thanks
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
quickly return to rep cordelia's line of
questioning on the destruction of
student data I think it doesn't make
sense to have an arbitrary
um year on there necessarily because as
you said kindergarten through 12
probably but in order to work with this
I think we all need to understand is
there any at all rationale
for if the third party maintaining these
Student Records after graduation for any
period of time or after disenrollment so
sit for example is a great example that
um right now either there's a very a
variety of reasons why you might want
your sat 10 years after you've taken the
SAT for example if you're becoming a
certified teacher and you need to take
this the Praxis you can opt out of
practice one is it if you've achieved a
certain score on Sat which is a great
benefit we're trying to actually
um make that more well known but that if
I wanted to be a certified teacher right
now I would have to go and find my SAT
score from early 2000s and hopefully
college board has it because I have no
record of it but
and if I may uh follow up
um
is there any current process or could
there reasonably any any reason why the
school districts could not maintain
those records instead of a private
entity third party
um well first of all um it does actually
say in here that
um so Statewide assessment results of a
student's shall not be included on the
students transcripts and so typically a
school maintains student transcripts but
not additional records on behalf of that
so that the law actually prevents that
right now
um but a lot of those they wouldn't
necessarily be accepted directly from a
school district it would mean for that
example it would need to come as it's
directly certified from the College
Board
thank you represent Luna thank you very
much Mr chair
um going back to the 95 how many schools
do we have in New Hampshire that uh have
participation levels below that
um 95 percent
so I I don't know
um I'll stop my head but one of the
things you can do with the I platform
system
um Is the participation rate is an
indicator So within the data system we
have on our website you can select that
as an indicator and that will show you
the participation rate for all schools
and districts in the state and you can
rank it so you'll be able to see you
know from lowest participation rate to
highest participation rate and get a
count of those schools and and to follow
up on that and so does the does the um
or let me ask another way could the
participation rate or could a low
participation rate
um contribute to a school being
identified as a as a CSI School
absolutely yeah so just to kind of
clarify the way that that's reported out
so we have the percentages of proficient
that we report on on I report so a
school might report out that they're 65
proficient that's just the proficiency
of the students who took the test so as
an example of 70 of your kids took the
test
65 of the 75 percent were proficient so
it's not proficiency of everybody
because we don't have that data we're
missing 30 so the zeros aren't factored
in that way it really is just the
proficiency of the kids who took the
test but then when you go to look at the
Essa indicators and whether schools CSI
or TSI that's where we Factor those
zeros in so a school might have 65
proficient which would not get them
labeled as a CSI school but if they're
missing 30 of the students and now count
as zeros that 65 is going to drop down
to you know 840 30 something percent and
now that school is being identified as
as underperforming because they're
missing data and that is where it's
counted so absolutely I would Hazard to
guess is we definitely have CSI schools
that were impacted by participation
rates in one form or another
and in those cases
yeah they're being identified as CSI
schools by the formula but it may not
necessarily indicate be in indicative of
of the student performance in those
schools correct yeah
represent McDonald thanks could you
direct me to where I can find this
contradictory federal law
yeah so the federal federal law is that
every student succeeds
okay and it's within the uh
um
section 1101 or 11 11 I think but I can
send you the specific reference okay
okay ready to move on
yep okay
um
because we went over the top of page 10
there we're asking why take that out
um
why why are we not keeping the portion
there on the top
uh where it says school district and
shall develop a form and it takes out
you know the alternative situation if a
kid doesn't take the test you provide an
alternative
sure it's the so the particular language
in here we had some discussions with
some superintendents in districts where
they had high percentages of parent
opt-out and one of the things that they
had struggled with was the language here
that says the alternative activity shall
be agreed upon by the school district
and the parent or legal guardian and
there have been uh struggles within the
field for districts and parents to agree
on what that alternative activity is
going to be and we haven't been able to
provide a lot of resolution necessarily
to that issue because
the statute just says they both have to
agree on it
um and so rather than have a requirement
here that the field is struggling to
implement because it seems like there's
some parents when they opt out want to
keep their kids home that day or they
want the kids to be able to participate
in a study hall the school may say well
we're going to have them do this
activity over here while the other
students don't have to do that it's been
a contention within the field so just to
sort of remove that because it's it
seemed to not really be happening
um we we pulled that language out of
this particular statute and that was a
conversation we'd had with
superintendents
okay any other items on that page Why
did it change it from commissioner to
department on the bottom there the
commissioner well you can even know more
about the legal part of that
commissioner shall adopt rules yeah so I
mean the commissioner doesn't adoptables
it's actually the State Board of
Education I was wondering we won't even
have the department but anybody yeah I
guess you could put the State Board of
Education but we were trying anytime
where I said the commissioner
specifically do something well we know
the commissioner doesn't have the
capacity to do every single thing where
it says the commissioner shall do it and
law so we tried to make it more generic
that you know if it says the department
will do it I might do it Nate might do
it maybe the commissioner will do it but
just kind of in the State Board I think
there's just some confusion when you say
something like the commissioner do it
and people are oftentimes looking for
the commissioner to be the actual person
doing it rather than the department as a
whole um and then again with the May
versus shell with a we don't currently
have rules around that so
would it be wise put State Board in
there
because there he that's the outfit that
does it I think he recommends yeah
carton recommends but I think we would
have to go back and look through the
rules but are the laws but the majority
of the time where it talks about rules
it says the department shall recommend
the rules it doesn't say this the State
Board
the department when we were doing some
legislation for the AG people across the
street and it had the department may
make rules yeah it's it's definitely
inconsistent
um throughout this whole book so
representative dry
thank you thank you I'd like to continue
this just there's a difference between
recommend rules and adopt rules I mean
who finally votes on the final version
maybe that's the person that shall be
is involved too
representative Damon
thank you I'm going back to the topic of
the earlier part of the page about
um
whose parents opt them out of the
testing
so you mentioned some parents wanting to
keep their children home and some
wanting them to have study hall
what else happens for those students
frankly those seem like inadequate
options to me
no
I'm not sure I'd be able to tell you I
we could reach out to some schools and
find out maybe on a case-by-case basis
the types of alternative activities
provided
after having been in the school trying
to do this
um you ran down to Personnel because at
some point it's every adult in the
building helping with the testing so if
there's a large group from different
grades not participate in the test
finding something to do with them that's
educational is virtually impossible
um because
even you have to have people available
if the teacher needs to take a break or
go to the bathroom you have to have some
so you know it's hard it's a hard
it's a big problem
especially if a lot of people opt out
thank you
the next page is where we start with uh
adequate education so perhaps is a good
time to take a break
and come back are you able to come back
we're here all day yeah you're you got
it all done Hey Okay so let's come back
and start this thing at one o'clock
yeah well that would follow this yeah
yeah
okay
or
foreign
was waiting for you to bring her lunch
good answer yeah
okay let's continue here
where you see chapter 193 adequate
are there any questions from the
committee for uh Caitlin and Nate on on
this page
go ahead one thing because you're going
to see it throughout here and I just
want to explain what we're doing
um so
previously this SEC this refers to the
minimum standards for public school
approval so a section of the minimum of
standards for public school approval but
not all of it so it's this section of
the law is specifically talking about
the criteria for an adequate education
that is actually the title right now
that's used in law but then it then it
refers to the public school minimum
standards approval so what we wanted to
do
because it was getting this is kind of
the terminology the number of times that
we use the word standards and you know
all competencies everything throughout
this it's it's hard to figure out we
also have minimum standards about data
privacy security approval and those are
minimum standards so we're not changing
the content of the minimum the of the
criteria for adequate education all we
are doing is we're changing their
reference to minimum standards for
public school approval to the criteria
for an adequate education which is
already the title and law and using that
throughout here
um just to help people understand what
the difference in those kind of terms
are
um so I just want you'll see that and
that's really what that is there are a
few I think that we might actually need
to go back in and double check that we
might have missed so we'll have to check
that as we go through but that's really
representative so like if I understand
what you're saying they're basically
trying to provide some consistency
rather than having minimum standards
here School District curriculum here yes
it's just to have it consistent exactly
because there's a whole section of
public minimum standards Public School
approvals that are in rules that is not
what this right here is referring to and
representative Belcher and then
represent Alexis
thank you Mr chair
um so when we make that change here uh
two criteria for an adequate education
because of the way adequate education
was uh suggested in the Supreme Court
decision sometime back Clermont I
believe it was how would changing this
language in this law that applies in
adequate education specifically with
these criteria to a public school
education how would that impact
non-public school education as opposed
to could we still say that's an adequate
education they're receiving if we do
this
this section RSA 198 93 e is
specifically to Public Schools it's not
for non-public schools so no changes for
non-public schools at all thank you
personally
that basically uh answered what I was
are there any yes represent cascadden
um I'm struggling a little bit with not
having any type of reference of to of
the minimum standards for public school
approval
coupled with adequate education
does one mean the same or are we
separating them so they mean two
different things
so yes and no right now when we talk
about the criteria for an adequate
education there are 12 different bullets
within 193 E2 a they're refer to
specific sections of the minimum
standards and so that's what this
particular section is calling out
and
we want to make sure that you know we're
clarifying when we talk about the
minimum standards for public school
approval there are a lot of things that
are in there that aren't called out
specifically in 183 e2a and that's the
clarification we're trying to make here
is it's not the full minimum standards
but it's specifically the minimum
standards related to the criteria for
inadequate education
correct yes correct yes yeah so there
are places in the section that's that
refer to the minimum standards as
defined by rsa19a3 e2a and you instead
of saying minimum standards is defined
in there you can just say the criteria
for adequate education it's the same
thing as opposed to referencing a set of
rules through a statute we can just
reference the statute and then that
statute references the role
okay
I think too if I may this this comes
under the section entitled adequate
public education
so my sense is when you refer to
education it's automatic it's under that
area so it's for public education right
correct
and you'll see as we go through the
different sections of accountability for
example we talk about ibas the input
based accountability system
the ibas only references those 12
sections in the criteria for inadequate
education which you can find in the
minimum standards and so throughout the
accountability sections here
we want to make sure that we're not
referring to the minimum standards in
its entirety but just the section of the
minimum of Standards relative to our
state assessment or relative to our
accountability system which it calls out
specifically that 193 e2a section
so from a policy perspective it doesn't
change anything it just changes the
title of what we're referencing to make
represent Tanner
thank you what you just said made me
think that
um it could mean that if if we're only
testing math English
um history science
uh that that then becomes the only
criteria for an adequate education
rather than the minimum standards so so
the criteria is still listed here in law
all we changed is the name but if you go
to page starting on through the
definitions
see but if you start on page 17 that's
where it defines what the criteria is
so right now it's a substantive
educational content for an adequate
education and current law we changed the
term the specific Criterion actually we
left the word Madam Sanders in here this
is an area we should have fixed well
that that actually should be because
this is where it makes the connection to
minimum standards so here it says this
is the criteria for an adequate
education it is the minimum standards in
these areas
and that's that's the clarification is
the minimum standards and Rule is a very
extensive document but the criteria for
inadequate education is called out in
statute as these particular sections of
the minimum standards and that's what we
want to make sure that we're being clear
about is there are times where we're
talking about all of the minimum
standards and there are times where
we're talking about just the minimum
standards called out in this particular
statute
so we're just essentially what we're
doing is we're trying to use a title to
refer to a specific so people are not
confused about all of them across the
board
so you're not redefining or trying to
Define adequacy no the definition that's
in current law is still here in this
so
I'm just not quite all there myself yet
um
I'm looking at 193 e colon 2 Dash a
which is the delivery or the substant
educational content of an adequate
education
and there it says under Roman 4 the
minimum standards for public school
approved for the areas identified in
paragraph one and those are those
11 areas that we have under adequacy
shall constitute the opportunity for the
delivery of an adequate education
so you're not in conflict with that
statement No that statement is still
on starting yeah see I you know I'm just
looking at the law book here in yes yeah
yeah so it's not in Conflict there it's
referring to that specific list of
criteria so that that list changed we've
not done anything to the definition of
that criteria and it does call it
specifically it's the minimum standards
in these areas of this paragraph and
that we have this bill does not propose
to change in any way the definition of
so when we look at minimum the words
minimum standards
are those referencing the minimum status
for public school approval
yes not the academic standards correct
I got it but you know I mean it took us
a long time to figure this out right so
this summer we were working with person
and carry on to kind of see what we were
supposed to be doing and we had our
white boards and we're drawing out maps
and it was it was it was tricky so I bet
yeah we're only on page 11. I jumped
this
I jumped I know it
okay so are there any more questions
that's where we started okay going on
again on page 12 in the bottom where it
says academic standards
I'd like to see be able to do in a
course
we we can mirror the standard
okay good
we'll mirror the definition that we used
from this morning
for that one so I'll make a note that
we're going to update that
on the bottom page uh 12 their mail yeah
yeah my sense is is that
when you eliminate
in a course
you're basically talking about a
competency rather than just an academic
learning
so is that is am I interpreting that
right standards tend to be at a little
bit more of a granular level so
competencies sometimes can represent a
single standard sometimes competencies
can be a collection of Standards so you
have three or four or five different
standards to roll up into a competency
it depends on the course it's being
taught
so if we go on the page of 13
that's where we have the definition of
competencies and we're talking about of
course a program of competencies
required for graduation we we didn't
mean to delete the definition of
Competency okay yeah we would like to
put that back in so that goes over on
the right hand side no when we were
going through this document
um when Jen first sent us like why did
we do this Nate and we just we
yes yes
we would like that added back in we like
to say a cat walked over the keyboard
how many times they walk over the
keyboard
I think I think John found everyone so
okay so we got competencies back in that
was a real question okay
um
anything else on that page page 13.
yeah
the number from 69 to 67 in the two
years was how was that changed why was
that change so the number 69 was used
when and then two years was used by this
group when we put together the law and
we changed it you know I don't remember
the reasoning behind that other than I
think maybe 67 felt low but there's not
a difference between 67 and 69 percent
um so we really wanted to go in and just
mirror the federal law which requires 67
percent yes thank you another Gene
digits you want to specify since we're
proposing changes
um is the superintendents requested that
we specify that it's the four-year
cohort because there is always confusion
around the four year or the five-year
cohort and that's what we do and that's
the current practice but we do agree
that the clarity could be used there we
also want to add a definition to the
word graduation rate because people are
confused about that so thank you I think
it was true
if you were to Google like I did at noon
time today the graduation rate in the
country which is much higher than 60
something percent it's close to 84 or 85
percent
and then when I looked at the title not
Title 20 Main
they have written into their law for
2015-16 the graduation rate will be 90
percent
why are we putting the bar so low
so it's it's a difference between what
we're measuring at the school level
versus the state level so sometimes some
of those plans are looking at it from a
state perspective so New Hampshire tends
to have a graduation rate Statewide of
between 90 and 95 percent sometimes it's
been higher than that we have a really
high graduation rate in the state this
is really just to identify the bottom
five percent and that's why that bar is
is set fairly low there is we don't
expect most high schools in the state to
be below that number in fact if if truly
we're only identifying five percent of
our schools it should be a relatively
small number of schools that are falling
so that's just representing the
comprehensive support
and Improvement school yes those are the
CSI schools so it's not a it's not a
Target or Benchmark for us as a state
it's just identifying what are the
lowest performing schools that have
graduation rates
so essentially for RCS high schools we
look at all of the bottom five percent
how they're doing but then we
automatically identify anybody with a
graduation rate of lower than 67 correct
um and so regardless of them being in
the bottom five percent or not so that's
a requirement right now with the federal
law and that's what we would like to
representative Luna
thanks very much Mr chair
um how's that going to apply how's this
graduation rate going to apply to
schools like vlax or um or maybe schools
that have a a high number of students or
high percentage of students who term out
when they turn 22.
so we we see that uh often with some of
our chartered public schools in the
state that have programs specifically
serving students that may have either
involved in credit recovery programs
they may be fifth year seniors that are
still looking to graduate but they've
already passed that point maybe they
were unsuccessful in previous programs
so it does disproportionately affect
schools that have programs focused on
that population of students but the good
news is that being identified as a CSI
school also comes with that additional
Federal monies and so if you have a
school that has a larger proportion of
students that are working towards
graduation beyond their senior year
you're going to now receive those extra
funds to be able to support that
particular group of students so in some
ways it's a messaging aspect if you're a
school that is doing good work you're
graduating kids in their sixth year of
high school you're going to have a low
four-year graduation rate but you're
still graduating those kids they just
might be taking five or six years to do
it
so this would only apply to full-time
enrolled be like students so when we
look at this particular data we filter
out any students that are in their
traditional like local public school
that happen to be taking vlx courses
yeah what's the consideration number for
of course they have to have be full-time
and vlogs
I don't know if there's a particular
course number for velax but it has to be
the school of record for that student
where vlx is the primary responsible
school they're enrolled as a a full-time
student and so be like in that case
would be receiving the majority of the
represent Tanner and then represent
Meyer and then thank you
um I noticed you took out the two
consecutive year part of it and it seems
like for example with covid that you
might have
years when you get a bump that might put
you below there and then you then you
come above it and it averages out is
there any reason
uh to take that out so our federal
requirements are 67 in the year that we
identify and then the state statute was
69 for two consecutive years so
essentially it was two different systems
of trying to identify the schools so we
just made it match our federal
requirements which didn't have that
consecutive year requirement
so it wasn't anything beyond just
aligning it with our federal
requirements do you see any advantage
keeping the two-year consecutive
for graduation rates not necessarily I
think the the pandemic obviously was a a
unique situation that we found ourselves
in
um we are looking at you know some of
our other indicators and whether there
might be value instead of looking at a
particular year but looking historically
at you know school's performance over
two years or the last three years
because we do see especially with things
like the pandemic there are impacts that
might affect a school in one year or in
two years but looking at you know a
school's performance over time might
give you a better picture of that so
it's something we're considering we
could make changes to our our state plan
and we've proposed some of those
historical changes in our next draft of
the state plan with the US Department of
Education
um we were going
uh so we don't necessarily have a well
we do have we have different levels so I
would have to take a look at the state
plan to see you know level one two three
or four of the percentage Yeah
yeah um I
we don't have any schools really that
fall most of our schools tend to to have
higher graduation rates we have more of
a bubble in the state and this really is
just looking at capturing what is the
lowest graduation rates in the state
Professor McDonald and representative
Myler
would there be schools in between the 67
and 69 percent that with this change
would no longer be included and would
lose funding as a result of the change
no because up to this point we've only
been identifying schools based off of
that Federal requirement so this is just
bringing this in line with what we've
been doing over the last few years and
we haven't been identifying schools
based off of the two years thank you
representative what uh how many more
schools will be in involved if you move
from 69 to 67 what's the impact in the
number of schools that it's gonna now
that's our the 67 is actually our
current practice because that's that was
the Federal requirement so we've been
using that 67 number already okay we
have not been using 69 so we could take
a look to see what the difference might
be
okay so
um level so to in terms of proficiency
language level three for graduation
rates is a 90 so if you're graduating
ninety percent
um to 93 that's a level three if you
have a graduation rate higher than 94
that's a level four so above proficient
in terms of graduate right proficiency
normal is academic achievement but in
terms of graduation rates
um level two would be 70 to 89 and then
below 70 we've identified as level one
but again if you're below the 67 it's an
automatic CSI identification so it's
represent Damon
thank you so the
draft language doesn't include the
statement about subsequent
determinations being made every three
years
so what is the time frame for evaluating
schools
so I believe it's later on in the
statute
um and it's a three-year cycle and we do
that it's the same it's just not the
same here correct yep thank you
representative Woodcock thank you sure a
question on your native follow-ups just
a minute ago if level one is below 70
and you're changing this to be 67 why
so we would still have some schools that
are so that's based on the level so we
would we would still have some schools
that potentially could be identified as
a CSI school because they are fall
within the bottom five percent so if
you're a level one and you have a bottom
five percent you might be identified for
that this is just based on an automatic
determination so it says it doesn't
matter if you need a bottom five percent
if you're the top 10 in the school in
the state but somehow you have a
graduation rate of lower than 67 you're
going to be automatically designated as
a CSI School
okay thank you
okay ready to move on
where'd you get the definition for
growth
that comes right from our state Essa
plan okay
growth was used in the section multiple
times but not defined as a lot of times
people ask us what growth means so we
thought it would be helpful to have a
definition
so can you explain a bit about the
student growth percentiles sure so I
can't give you the math equation it's a
little bit above my head but from a kind
of a conceptual basis what we do is we
take a group of students that performed
all the same level so for example fifth
graders that all scored and I'll make up
a number here let's say they all scored
a 240 on the reading test so in their
fifth grade year they were all at
exactly the same level we take just that
group of students and we look to see
what was their performance on reading in
sixth grade how did those students grow
compared to each other so we talk about
student growth percentile it's the
students that are in the percentiles
compared with each other based off of
everybody that was at the same level the
previous year and we do that for every
score on the test so then we look at all
the kids that scored a 261 how do they
do the next year and if you're in the
95th percentile means that compared to
your similar peers the prior year you
grew after academically more than 95
percent of that group versus if you're
in the 10th percentile you only grew
more than 10 percent of the students
that scored the same way you did the
previous year
but it gets mathematically a little bit
complicated so we actually look at the
previous two years and we kind of factor
in a a model that predicts what how
students should be growing based off of
comparisons to their own peers so it's
not necessarily whether they're
proficient or not proficient but it's
looking at their similar peer group how
much they continue to grow great on
grade on the state assessment
oh yeah
yep so are those student percentiles and
assessments of growth
district-wide school-wide Statewide
Statewide
okay thank you
yes representative thank you thank you
same thing on this fall up to seven
percent so Pace here and the definition
of growth Pace would mean the percentage
the number you're talking about they
move through the Pacific the percentage
of movement
yeah yeah exactly
um a kind of a metaphor if you think
about
um if you've got a whole bunch of cars
that are stopped I understand
but that's what pacemet in this
definition represents oh yeah the pace
of student yes yes
I was thinking about Pace from before
yep two different ad space yeah thanks
how much time is usually involved in the
test interval between when you start and
where you're measuring is it a year
it's it's generally about a year it can
vary schools have a pretty large testing
window it opens up usually around the
end of March and goes through about the
beginning of June so it depends on when
further questions represent cordelli
thank you just wondering if these
definitions
would be reflected on the I platform
definition section uh what's there now
is that the current
um and then you would once finalized
with the Senate version you would move
them over to that or is it a combination
of the two I think that's a great point
that you brought up we should double
check that they reflect the same thing
yes for the most part they should yeah
they should be helping but that's that
is a good reminder for us to do that if
this is
and I wrote in one thing after your
definition here and I just
when you say growth means measurement of
the pace of student achievement over
time on the Statewide assessment yeah as
measured using student growth
percentiles
there are that are consistent with
statistical
yes and we can we can make predictions
when we look at achievement and growth
together side by side so for example you
might have a student who is in the below
proficient range and compared to the
rest of their peers we know on a
percentage basis how much growth they
have to make in order to move from say
below proficient to approaching
proficient so we can use that
statistical analysis to create these
predictive models and estimate how much
growth do students need to make each
year to move from where they're at up to
a level of proficiency
and that's one way actually that we
measure our English language Learners
specifically each year we have to track
whether they're on track to meeting
proficiency within five years and we use
this model of growth to make sure is the
pace of student achievement following
that expected path of growth so that
within five years they're becoming
proficient in English language
okay let's move on to page
15.
your definition of school here is this
relevant is this just relevant to RSA
193e
yes everything in e 193e
because there's references to other
types of schools within this area of
adequacy queer technical education
not not within this section though in
yeah I'm looking at let's see 193e
four
[Music]
think
go ahead no
so as you I'm concerned about the issue
we're authorized by New Hampshire State
Board of Education
and what other kinds of schools
might be defined I'll give you some
examples
for example with prenda could that be a
pot of friend that could that be defined
by the the
State Board as a school another example
might be a learning center where EFA
students come together periodically
to share resources Etc
so that's my first question is what
other kinds of schools are we talking
about one and two
by that definition once they reach a
definition would they then qualify for
adequacy Aid if it's approved by this if
those kinds of schools I just talked
really
so the the schools that are approved by
the State Board of Education have in
State Statute very specific
processes for approval so non-public
Schools public schools and Charter
Schools there's whole sections of law
that that require that so
I would think that you know to
have Brenda approved by the State Board
of Education you would have to write a
prenda approval section and then then
require the friend of school to ensure
that they're providing an adequate
education through ibas and pbas
and then then also write a separate
section saying that they would be
eligible for Aid so I think that would
need
entirely separate legislation outside of
this section here we're trying to find
here who is required to participate in
ibas and pbas essentially
so you're saying you're saying that in
order for
a non-traditional School
to be approved under this language
they would have to comply with the other
parts of the law that defines
specifically what a public school would
be is that correct
represent Tanner thank you so a school
approved for tuition purposes
um that approval is with the school
board that contracts with the school I
think that is correct okay so that is
beyond
uh just being authorized by the new by
the New Hampshire State Board of
Education isn't that school doesn't is
not required to provide adequate
education through this definition it's
not required to participate in ibas and
pbas the local school district is
responsible for ensuring that they're
providing a school an adequate education
but that school that they're tuitioning
they don't they don't when they do the
approval they don't have to they aren't
compelled to to
to provide an adequate education for
their students the items the items
within 193 to a so that that 12 bolted
list to refer back to the minimum
standards there's a requirement in
school tuition programs that those items
are outlined in the contract between the
local school district and the tuition
program so it's not that the tuition
program has to follow 193e to a but
they're required to adhere to the
contract that they have with the local
public school which must include
elements that you can find within there
so it's it's similar but it's not quite
the same if that makes sense there's
elements of the adequate education but
it's they don't have to comply with the
statute they have to comply with the
contract that they've written with the
yes representative Cascade can I just
carry that a little further so that I
can understand
from Representatives Tanner's question
on tuition schools
they have to comply the contract that
they have with the public school
but they don't have to meet adequate
education or minimum standards
and still get adequacy Aid
because that makes the adequacy aid goes
to the local public school and then that
local public school has a contract by
which they're paying a certain amount
for the tuition for the students are
going to those programs and then that
contract has other requirements that are
outside of this section I believe it's
in
194 something it does reference this
section but it references it in terms of
what's required in the contract that the
local school district creates so they do
have to follow certain aspects of
inadequate education because it's
required to be in the contract but that
tuition program is not held to this
specific statute it's a separate statute
okay and I think I'm confusing
tuition school with
right non-public schools oh okay
right
some of them may be non-public schools
okay
president Miler now it just occurred to
me as we look at these changes and
others that we'll be looking at
how are they complying with the proposed
so the 306 standards set up the
requirements in many of those areas that
are then referenced from this particular
statute so those those particular
criteria reference the 306s if there are
changes made to those 306 standards then
those would be the standards that this
is this is referring to so once well I
know you're going through a series of
public hearings now which is great to
get a lot of input once those standards
have been approved by the state board
somewhere in the future
there will then be another review
of how those standards comply with the
current law and the current law then
would have to be changed no so the
current law refers to the sections of
standards and those sections of stand so
the law states the law
um and it just refers to a section of
standard so that section of Standards
might change but the law is still going
to refer to that section
that makes sense so this proposal
essentially is entirely unimpacted by
the current minimum standard change
or proposed change and then when I must
have missed it when the proposed changes
are enacted how does how do they then
relate to this so This section of law
refers to those
those sections but this is not changing
so if they were
so the changes to and maybe if you go
this might be actually a question for
page 17. okay yeah because then you can
yes represent Damon
thank you
you may have already answered this but
I'm not clear
what are or who are
the schools that are the or in this
statement so the or authorized by the
New Hampshire State Board of Education
since it's or they're not District
public they're not chartered public
they're not public academies so who are
they
um there might be a couple of situations
so uh Rivendell for example is an
interstate school that is primarily
operated by Vermont that includes New
Hampshire students in it and there's an
authorization by our state board of
education to allow those students to
attend Rivendell but they remain New
Hampshire Public School students we have
many schools that are authorized under
our Bureau of special education to act
as private providers that are out of
state so they're authorized by the State
Board of Education to provide
specialized special education services
in a residential placement but they may
exist in Massachusetts or Connecticut or
South Carolina so there are examples
where we have authorized schools but
they're not necessarily A New Hampshire
school
and those students are still required to
follow-up
so I understand that clearly thank you
but this doesn't limit that definition
to those kinds of schools
across state line special ed or a shared
School District I think we can certainly
can I yeah we can clean up the
definition I'm not married to this
definition personally so
Partners
right now there's no definition of
school so that's what you're trying to
there are a number of school
environments in here we use as a measure
an indicator of delivering an adequate
education
and I'm going to go back to Career
Technical education again when we had to
commission back
several years ago there was discussion
that came from another member who was on
the CTE advisory Council that why isn't
CT part of adequacy
and when I'm seeing it identified
555 of the law book here which is 193e
colon 3 when we talk about the number
and percentage of students earning a
career in Tech education outcome and
then I see it later when we talk
specifically of CTE students on page 556
which are also
um
a part of the indicator for receiving
that opportunity for an adequate
education so are those not considered
schools
I know they're within a school district
but there you know they are
separate buildings facilities for a
separate purpose
so generally those are considered
programs there are CTE centers that are
are large enough that have enough
offerings that really are considered
Standalone schools but they're operated
by districts and for the most part CT
programs exist as one opportunity that
students can access as part of a larger
District's curriculum so to to really be
considered a school they would have to
be able to follow all aspects of the
adequate education the minimum standards
they'd have to be diploma granting so
it's it's certainly something that you
could do but I don't think all of our
CTE centers necessarily fit that
definition
that's right yeah
going down
going down to the very bottom of uh 15
you've eliminated
a whole suction
that deals with TSI schools
why is that
Jesus
because what's this section in
because I think we just refer back to
the plan so I think I think we don't use
TSI through I think we just refer back
to the plan I don't think we're actually
using TSI and of itself so this we just
removed the definition we can double
check that but I think that's why we did
that okay that's good thank you wasn't
used independently
um we do actually need to talk about CSI
versus TSI when we come further on
um and that might be the reason for that
that's why this movie defined separately
I think it's yeah it is defined
separately so we need yeah the content
itself sort of just moved to another
section and there's a lot of language
that we actually removed only because
it's just duplicative of the plan and we
didn't feel like it was necessary to
have it if we were referring back to the
state plan I think for example
um on representative lab was just
talking about
um where we refer on page 555 to the
College and Career Readiness indicators
I believe we completely removed those
and just referred to back to the college
in your career at Readiness indicators
as a defined in the plan and then that
way that gives us the flexibility if we
were to go in and add an additional
indicator in the future we wouldn't need
to go in and write rewrite the law we
would just not modify the plan
so you think that this language is
someplace else
um or not used because we just refer to
it
just gets back to us on that yes we'll
okay Ellen say that again about the
indicators you're saying that you have
not included the indicators
oh let's double check that so the so the
indicators yeah the indicators
themselves are included later on
um in the performance-based
accountability system
um we we discuss how the that system is
aligned to the data and indicators
that's within the state Essa plan and
that way we reference specifically which
indicators we're talking about it is the
indicators aligned with our state plan
whereas before it just referenced the
pbas in general but wasn't specific to
where the indicators came from we wanted
to actually make sure that people
understood within the statute when we
talk about pbas it's the indicators from
foreign
so we are right now anything on the
bottom page 16 or there that you saw
just just a clarification on why the
so the word learning when you look at
the minimum standards that are being
referenced here the minimum standards
are either education programs or it just
refers to education it doesn't use the
word learning so we removed learning
areas because in the minimum standards
none of those sections are defined as a
learning area they're defined as either
we didn't want people to go looking for
a learning area it was called that here
does everybody comprehend what was just
said there
no I don't either okay so in the minimum
standards each of these areas English
mathematics science they're called
programs so learning areas
well so in the middle of Standards
they're referred to as program areas and
here in the statute talks about learning
areas so we could change one or the
other I think it's just helpful to make
them consistent I think
we just got rid of the descriptor and
just an area it can be a learning area
everything used to be known as a subject
area
okay the subject area that could be
ready yeah content area so we just use
the word area so then that can compare
you so because the areas are very
clearly defined as you know as below so
why don't you put following content
areas
it does actually use the word content in
the in the title there so that's it
that's funny because in Roman numeral
nine years again and it's not struck out
so let you each time I know so Nate
you're good with that I I'm yeah I
hesitate to point out that in the next
paragraph it also uses learning areas
and we did not strike that out so we may
want to do the same
taking Roman numeral nine change that to
no you said Roman nine
we should be consistent be consistent
thank you
Mr chair yes uh why again why was the in
when you deal with art education
the elimination of music and visual arts
do we Define art education someplace
else that includes that so there are two
lists that existed in statute and they
had some minor differences with each
other
I thought we had kept that in so on one
side it has
so on page 22 it does include that
no it doesn't
do it is that removed
yeah it is in the minimum standards when
you look at the Arts education program
music and visual arts are part of those
standards whether we call them out here
or not
um
I it was not I don't think it was an
intentional I think we're just cleaning
up to match the titles that were within
the minimum standards we were matching
the titles and the minimum standards so
there's a whole area in the minimum
standards has Arts education and within
that section it says music and visual
arts and they're defined there further
so when we're looking at the titles of
the minimum standards that's what we're
doing
so whether it's here or not schools are
still required to do it because it's in
well we put in the the subjects after
social studies we did that with adequacy
but last year and then we did the other
with the health and and Welfare and that
also came right out ab306 yeah which we
so
so for example with social studies you
do have many different areas those are
all part of one section in the minimum
standards called social studies except
for Holocaust and genocide which is a
separate section of the minimum
standards
we can add that back in we're perfectly
fine editing that back in yeah and it's
it is a case of is there a specific
intention of calling out music and
visual arts specifically because Arts
education also includes performing arts
and dance in the minimum standards so
that's in the minimum standards but it's
not specifically called out here yet we
do call out music so I think part of it
is an intention
um and I'm not arguing one way or the
other way it's if you say Arts education
it's going to be everything in arts
education which is going to also include
things like pottery and artistic
expression Dance Performing Arts so
we could call everything out we could
call some parts of it out we could just
say Arts we could just say social
science I think it really that makes
sense
100 Cascade
um I think I think it originally aligned
with certifications because it social
studies teacher is not certified in
history Civics and all those different
sub categories whereas in science right
you can get a biology cert chemistry
cert physical science cert
and I and it's the same for Arts
um so I'm wondering if that's why
there's a shift of language in different
places
I don't really have a question but I'm
trying to think why you have subsets of
science
and some subsets of Arts and that social
studies all in one Clump it made me
think of teachers are certified
along those
areas I mean I I just I mean I know that
social studies has been wrote most
recently modified and continued to add
and like these are the more some of the
more recent changes in some of these
areas
um but I I mean for consistency purposes
I think we'd like to do either
all or none so I think we either like to
match the minimum standards perfectly or
so when we look at 193c you know the
area we talked about assessment
193 C5 colon 5.
it lets out history geography civics
in economics
and
so we list them separately it's no
um
they are separate learning areas really
within just like you can have within
Science Biology botany and everything
else
and I think this is a good like a good
example of we should probably make all
three lists while we eliminated the
third list made a second list and maybe
go back to the assessment side of things
and make that list similar and it's it's
very hard for us to kind of explain I
mean we can't even do it to you I'll
explain why there's a difference of
these lists and that's what we're saying
like let's be consistent throughout
everywhere
I'll make them all the same yeah yeah
boom easy
so is so we'll help draft this is the
preference of the committee to make them
same as the titles in the areas of the
minimum standards does that make the
most sense make them all the same
if they're all titles yeah that way okay
yes represent all
Mr chair I would think that on page 22
that's a list we came up with last year
I would think that's a list that we
should do
because I remember when it came to us we
didn't have digital literacy the Senate
added digital literacy
one of the problems we had was when we
broke down the content for a substantive
uh education
then we went to the delivery and there
were two different columns we didn't
match them up
right and that that's what we noticed
too yeah that's that's the problem right
and so we've just said all right now
let's just use the one that's here under
rsa193 on page 17 and eliminate the one
on page 22 and reference back to just
17. so then we have just one section
so then we'll make them all the same
exactly
pardon me
is there another session no no no no
down in ten what page you on I'm on 18.
I'm still on 18. okay good uh on the 10
you said uh you added the Define the
school year and minimum credit
where is that defined where where is the
uh and how does that is that part of the
again going back is that part of the 306
consideration it is so each of those are
defined in the 306s
um the minimum school year is actually
defined both in statute I think in 190
189 10 or 189.1 where you can have a
school year of 180 days or an equivalent
number of hours and then the minimum
standard sets out what those equivalent
hours are and then the minimum credit
requirements for a high school diploma
is also set out in the minimum standards
but the reason why this is added in here
because if you go to page 23 in your
document when we said we had the two
different match to unmatching
groups of items so school year
requirements and minimum standard for
high school diploma are here already on
page 23. so thank you we said if we're
going to make the two lists match so we
needed to put everything in that list
here and then refer back to that area
so
because we start we I think we initially
did eliminate that because we said well
there's already a law that defines that
someplace else but we said we're just
going to make the two areas match we
foreign
thanks so so I'm sort of I think we're
sort of on pages 17 18 19 because it's
all yeah turning into that but just
going to the to the top of um of section
e2a on um on 17
does do the changes
um
there
make any sort of material change into
into
who or what what organization has the um
the responsibility
for
ensuring that um
that these now what are being called
minimum standards
are in place
in uh in the school
no not at all
and if are you are yeah
yeah in the current law you know we're
we're we're we're seeing that these are
defined and identified as school board
I'm sorry as school approval standards
and uh in the following learning areas
and um and now it's
minimum standards in the following areas
and I'm I'm just
um
you know just just wondering if if
these changes as well as as well as
others leading up to this uh make a make
a material change into into
um you know who's got the responsibility
for making sure that these standards are
being met so the full title of the
regulation is the minimum standards for
public school approval right and you
sort of got half the title here and half
the title here but I think in other
places we refer to it as the minimum
standards in the following areas so
again it was it was making it consistent
but they both whether we talk about
public school approval standards or
minimum standards it's the same set of
regulations okay okay
um and then and then a sort of a knit
comment
um I've noticed on some prior pages and
where did I see it 1920
you know
of
this term used for um for public schools
is sometimes coming down as as District
Public Schools sometimes it's public
district schools and and um and I don't
know what we want to settle on on that
but uh but probably something you know
schooled you know
um
I don't know
yeah I would argue that's that's the
case throughout this entire box
assistant yeah yeah so we would love to
see that consistency from page one to
about page 600 yeah yeah yeah and and
then and then sort of related to that
Charter Public Schools fall into two
categories State chartered public
schools and District chartered Public
Schools so is there a difference between
a a district public school and a
district chartered Public School in
terms of okay okay so that's free
um for an adequate education yes from a
from a governance standpoint yes yeah so
that there are there are significant
differences and then there are overlaps
where there are no differences right
yeah okay
so what are you talking the difference
between a conversion Charter and a rigor
Charter not so a conversion chart would
be if it was a traditional public school
that turned into a charter school so the
governance is that way but I think we
can also open a chartered school that's
still a District chartered school or
there can be a standalone State
authorized Charter Public School so you
theoretically could even have three
options though two of them are operated
by the district and the governance is
interrelated within the public school
district as opposed to being a
standalone operating chartered Public
School
okay
um are we on page 19
in there somewhere yeah on on Roman 12
there were says Public District Schools
Etc
adhere to the standards are those those
are minimum standards right
so we're talking minimum standards
should we have consistency there or if
you're just talking standards is that
same as minimum standards
identify
and this may so yeah if we go back up to
eight
everything
that's the list of the minimum standards
so you're referencing back to the
minimum standards the minimum standards
in that particular list and so it's 12
correct
so as we're taking out this um on
several places uh for public school
approval for public school approval we
did that back a few things
it
does that Define a school what is a
public school versus what is a
non-public school no
there's a whole separate section of
there's a whole separate section of law
that talks about a non-public school and
then the approval process for that and
it's completely separate from this so
I guess you know I I have always been
kind of confused of why Charter Schools
all of a sudden became Charter Public
Schools and when you have the public
district schools the Charter Public
Schools and public academies and then
you're taking away for public school
approval
um
as part of the narrative about these
schools and also to ensure the delivery
of an adequate education it it just it I
don't know if it's just me but it seems
like we're taking away removes
what what's a public school approval
I think it's the difference in the
intent of the regulations themselves so
this refers specifically to the criteria
for inadequate education and that's been
defined by the legislature as a specific
set of the public school approval
minimum standards
so the public school approval standards
in their entirety still apply to all
schools and there's a separate process
the department can conduct that is a
school approval process this doesn't
change any of that and that's why we've
pulled that out a little bit because
when it talks about public school
approval in this section it's not
relative to approving a public school
it's really relative to whether school
is providing a minimum adequate
education and the school approval
process lives outside this section and
but uh
if you take adequacy standards away from
the definition of a public school
approval then
then how do you I mean then any school
any school could either it's all on the
same level they all get approved or
non-approved and it doesn't matter if
they're Public Schools Charter Schools
non-public schools you know what I mean
yeah they're a separate approval
processes for uh if you're a non-public
school or charter school or a public
school so when we talk about adequate
education or adequacy adequacy is a
subset of the school approval rules but
the school approval process itself is
much larger than adequacy and so that's
what we're trying to pull apart here is
that when we say School approval School
approval and adequacy are not
necessarily the same thing adequacy
lives within School approval but School
approval itself is a much larger process
that exists outside of this section and
when we're in this section of Statute we
want to refer only to the minimum
standards relative to adequacy
so isn't isn't adequacy though the
Prime reason
for schools I mean isn't that the prime
reason the the reason we Define adequacy
is because that's like the basis of a
I don't know yeah you can go on it just
so I mean do you think it's something
you think of public school right and so
adequacy is the core yes and then
there's layers on top of it right and so
what we're trying to do this section
right here is specific to the core so to
do the to kind of ensure that you have
the core you're offering these sections
that are here right here and then as a
result we're then assessing to make sure
that you're right operating those
sections and then we're providing
funding associated with those sections
then there's minimum schools approval
which is layers on top of that and
that's that whole minimum standards for
public school approval all of the 306s
which extend to areas Beyond this and
then there's other laws throughout this
whole book that public schools have to
apply or
comply with rather that are not
necessarily part of adequacy so it's
kind of all of these different multiple
layers right now right here what we're
trying to do is just Define that the
core layer and then we'll go on from
that and then we can start taking part
of other sections but we just need that
for that base section first and that
core makes it a public school right
that school that core makes it providing
an adequate education
or what some people term a government
School
there's other things you have to do to
be a government school okay outside of
providing an adequate education that
exists in the minimum standards or
right
you look at the first page in your
statute it's the very first page
on um
Roman 2 C it says the Paramount goal of
the state shall be to provide an
adequate education
so that's our primary goal I think
that's where you're going represent
Tanner yes
okay
foreign
yeah well I like the uh have an
explanation for the addition of uh 16
was
so 16 exists currently in statute it's
on page 21 we just moved it because we
had re-numbered some of it so it looks
like it was pulled out here but it's
actually on the next page
so it's current Length Kids current
any other questions for these pages
no I'm on 20. I'm in the um the center
version
did we move the the legislative
oversight committee
from coach statute to we did we did we
moved it from the assessment law to the
accountability law because so more about
accountability than assessment okay so
we felt it better it lived in this
section better okay and
have we already looked at that
no I think it's later okay here we
didn't change anything we just moved it
didn't change anything and and uh what
what's what's the current statutory
it's currently under is that
NCAA
Rick do you remember where that I'm
trying to
it's in C8
foreign
the reason I'm bringing this up so so
c8a which is the oversight committee
right now has some review and approve
language in it and
and
Roman 17 talks about prior review and
recommendation and I'm just I just want
to make sure because prior review and
recommendation are completely different
than review and approve and and I want
to make make sure that there's no
foreign
that the oversight committee would be
would be seeding some sort of
um responsibility that a statutory
and I'm so in terms of Roman numeral 17
when we talked about academic standards
so that review and recommendation is
relative to the academic standards which
are the the larger standards documents
that like next Generation science
standards Common Core
um and then I think there may be some
additional language somewhere else that
also then refers to minimum standards so
sometimes it may be a difference between
what are the responsibilities of that
oversight committee relative to minimum
standards or academic standards or which
particular standards are we talking
about too right right and I think and
and you know my understanding is that
the academic standards aren't just
um you know revised social studies
curriculum or revised you know science
standards but um
but tied into the statute
um the academic standards and
and
and I guess I I would defer to the chair
you know the the position that the that
the law takes on what the um uh what the
oversight committee's responsibility is
when it comes to uh to minimum standards
and academic standards I know uh chair
Ladd and I have had several
well on that note though if I may
why is why is that one uh wise paragraph
so we had moved the definition of
academic standards to the front of that
section so now when you read it it
should have that definition academic
standards at the beginning of the
section as opposed to referring to the
particular statutory reference that was
there before we just moved all the
definitions to the front of the section
this was a problem we found throughout
this legislation there was Randomness
definitions just not in definition
sections and then it was referred to so
we tried to put them all in the same
place
foreign
where where is the connection I guess
between academic standards as you've got
it defined in um in row and
e2a Roman six
and
the responsibilities that the committee
under 190 so this this would be
um
performance targets required under 193
H2 and I think the committee has a lot
so there are there are three places that
provide I think three distinct levels of
oversight
um two of them specifically call out the
oversight committee so in the oversight
committee section
um they have the authority to I believe
review and approve the performance
targets and the performance targets are
all the targets that are written into
the Essa estate plan so back in 1718
when we first drafted that that was when
we set all of those performance targets
where we wanted schools to be
um we had interim benchmarks we had
long-term targets and and so that's what
that's referring to there specifically
performance targets in Roman numeral 17
here this talks about the academic
standards and that the oversight
committee shall have prior review and
recommendation of those those are the
standards we use to build the state
assessment so again back in you know
1617 we did that for the science test
for the science standards it was a
couple years before that we did it with
the English and math standards
specific to minimum standards
um I'm gonna go to the law book yeah
page 550 is 193 E2
a
Roman numeral
4 B
and this one refers to the legislative
oversight over the minimum standards
neither the Department of Education nor
the State Board shall by Statute or rule
require oh I'm going to skip down a
little bit where is it uh sorry letter C
the State Board shall not amend any
existing academic standards shall not
approve any new academic standards
rather prior review and recommendation
of legislative oversight committee
established in RSA 183 c8a so there's
that
um sorry the top of page 50. oh oh c
you're on c yeah so that's that's this
new Roman numeral 17. yeah but if you go
down a little bit further
um
which ones you're looking for now
so there's one that requires the
approval of the general court
and that one's relative to minimum
standards
I thought I'd have been right in that
section
the concern that I have is that we've
got academic standards means what a
student should know and be able to do
and of course or at each grade level
and and I think that may have been
changed earlier to eliminate the
Intercourse so it's it's in the the
paragraph prior to that so at the bottom
of page 549 Roman numeral four
this one now refers specifically to the
minimum standards and the Court's
so academic standards are the ones that
we use for the assessment and the
oversight committee has review and
approval Authority there
in paragraph four the minimum standards
talks about approval by the general
court and that's the paragraph prior to
the academic center so it exists
independently in two sections right
right yeah but I guess what I'm getting
at
um
Nate is that in in the definition of
academic standards you're talking about
what a student should know and be able
to do and and then in the um in the
oversight committee's charge it says
review and approve Statewide performance
targets which
um
I I would think are related to what a
student should know and be able to do
um so I you know I I don't think there's
necessarily a clean separation
um uh between what the responsibilities
of the of the oversight committee are
and it's Authority in um you know
in the area of academic standards
um
and so so that's the concern I've got
over Romans 17 is that uh it's saying
the State Board shall not amend any
existing academic standards and shall
not approve any new economic standards
without the review and recommendation of
the oversight committee
um I I think the oversight committee
might have greater
um
greater Authority down the review and
approval
um
and so we haven't so that's current
statute we haven't changed that yeah
yeah no I well it's moved around but
right
well this isn't an area where we have to
be very careful yeah yeah very very
careful we lost this a year ago
and we got to put back in
and we had North or the a year ago it
was all gone it stripped
that the whole law was deleted
right for the for the oversight for the
oversight yeah so our belief is that
this bill doesn't change your oversight
ability at all or well if you're other
committees oversight committee we
believe that this keeps everything
exactly the same the only differences
are you seeing a difference it I guess
representative luno um
well I mean the the the fact that we're
the fact that we're moving it I think
opens up the uh the the door to uh to
how it could be interpreted because it's
it it you know when when when when
current law has basically evolved over I
don't know how many you know countless
years a little bit here a little bit
here and a little bit here and now we're
re-codifying you're you're you're you're
essentially taking a now we're putting
this into law and we all agree this is
this is how it is as opposed to
something that developed and may have
had some irregularities and may have had
some conflicts in it
um now when we put it in we're we're
doing it in in in you know Eyes Wide
Open that that um to the Confluence and
I think where when when we when we do a
recodification uh like the state has
done recently with the trust laws and
and lot and some other areas that um
that it's the opportunity not just to
move stuff around and renumber them but
to uh to to address policy where there
where may have been either incomplete
inconsistent or in Conflict okay and
that makes sense I just that was not the
intention of intention of us to move to
do other than anything but other than
put it someplace where I made more sense
right I mean because when we read it
about the oversight committee and even
we've been working with oversight
committee because that's Nate and I that
do that work as well like this is not
really just about assessment it's about
a much broader oversight of State
accountability
specifically around an adequate
education and that's why we have felt it
belonged in this session rather than
just the assessment section the
assessment section is obviously used for
the measurement as part of the
measurement of an adequate education but
this this oversight Community felt was
was broader
yeah I and I agree with you I think it I
think it is broader and um and and maybe
because of that prior review and
recommendation isn't really applicable
uh anymore but but maybe the terms
review and approve are are more more
applicable because you know if if the
oversight committee has has uh review
and approve of performance targets but
but minimum standards and academic
standards are somehow moving around I
don't know how I don't know how the
oversight committee does performance
targets if other standards can be moved
around out outside of the uh the
committee's um
foreign
too too much about it I know the last
time we were here
um we kind of gave just a very brief
sort of you know our intention really
was to do as much cleanup as we could
with this and we recognize as well there
are things that we would love to either
make better or more efficient that would
represent a more substantive policy
change for some of the work that we do
um and we sort of see it as like the
next step is we're trying to sort of get
the law back into a good place now with
how we currently operate in the field
and then let's take that next step of
really digging into it and saying okay
so what what can we do to improve
schools and students and adequate
education from a more policy perspective
hmm
okay let's let's move on well let me
just ask this one just uh the reason for
the elimination of the public school
approval
in paragraph old four
in the paragraph new uh 18 giving you've
eliminated for public school approval I
just what was the basis for the removal
of that language because we're just
using that minimum standard that we
defined back in page 12.
um 14. we have minimum standards to find
now it's a minimum standards means
minimum standards for public school
approval
so we actually gave it that definition
and are using it throughout this
consistently
further on that page
okay let's go to page 21.
I just text her we're not resolving
everything today no no no we're
yes
suspension he just said she's gonna
bring them to the ground
Mr Jim yeah I'm asking if maybe it would
clarify some of our discussion if we
made a small amendment in terminology
when we're talking as in this section
here section
uh
six I believe it is
um
minimum standard for public school
approval
what if we called it minimum
programmatic standards
program standards yourself so the
minimum Center for Public School
approval um is throughout Rule and and
it is a very specific connotation
the minimum standard for public school
approval has a very specific connotation
at the section of rule that's approved
when you're talking about the minimum
standards for public school we wouldn't
want to start messing with that
definition
um and that's why we tried to kind of
use two different delineations here when
we're talking about the minimum standard
from public school approval versus the
content of an adequate education but
when we're talking about that that is
rules that are adopted by the state
board right now and we wouldn't want to
change
um I just don't do want to point out
here so all of these definitions are
Incorporated back on page 12 on the
definition section so that's all we're
One Way lastly list thank you very much
I didn't understand that
um when we list all the areas where the
English language arts etc etc
we don't distinguish between which is
the second language we don't consider
English for speakers of other Esau
speakers of other languages we don't
leave that for the schools to decide
so it's two separate programs yeah so
when we talk about uh English language
arts here it's an English language arts
program for all students title III for
English language Learners tends to be a
separate program in schools has a
different set of standards and
assessments that we use and it works
simultaneously to our regular English
language arts program
so they're two separate programs
essentially okay but the word standards
creates us a linguistic problem because
standards say you know what is the
standard ABC whatever you've got
something measurable and then what we're
talking about here is programs and we're
saying okay we decided we
beat the center if we have a program
but does the program meet the standard
needed to solve this also my problem my
concern and and we are not doing a
program approval here we are talking
specifically about standards I
understand we're trying to talk about
those as though there are no standards
elsewhere
you see what the word standards
[Music]
we've had all kinds of standards in the
past we try to we had the education
standards at one time and nobody knew
what that meant we had academic
standards minimum standards you know
it's I think we gotta start boiling it
down oh and we completely agree uh it's
and we're using everything in different
ways and we're confused it's hard for us
to explain things to the schools so and
that's what we're trying to do a lot
throughout this document
um
and we just need to be better we us I
mean even things like we just don't use
consistent terminology throughout this
law book and it's something that we
absolutely need to do and the thing is
very frequently completed public school
or sorry non-public school and private
school those are like inflated but we
don't have a definition of private
school so then you write it a law it
says private school we don't necessarily
know what that is so
yeah
okay page 22.
yes just a question that makes me wonder
this list um
of definitions we've talked today about
two
uses of minimum standards one for public
school approval and one that describes
adequate education correct correct
though I know one is built from the
other
but just I mean if you think it makes
sense because it didn't dawn on me till
today that minimum standards that we
talk about for an adequate education is
different
to some extent with minimum standards
for public school approval whether that
definition of minimum standards to meet
adequacy
should be added there or not I think
that's why we're going to use the word
criteria for an adequate education
rather than right whatever the term is
so that it's consistent with the law but
I think it would make sense to break it
out
just because they are two different
entities not for me to decide you no
we're in real but we've talked about it
in two meanings and I'm thinking well
correct
right but it should probably be included
in this list of definitions well so
we've can on 22 we've completely struck
out this last but there's some
definitions and we've just referred back
to the list of definitions on page yeah
it just begins on page 17 now
so it's not listed two separate times
because this is another area that it was
listed twice mostly the same but very
if I'm reading this correctly that
you've made a change I'm looking at the
first section under the
the second section where you it seems to
be that if the school was to demonstrate
and now you're talking about the
department
uh why why the change so so previously
so it said that schools will demonstrate
but the department has to implement the
accountability system we're the ones
that are doing implementing the
assessment we're the ones that are going
to take all the school scores aggregate
those together rank all of the schools
were there ones that are gonna
implement the ibass and ask the schools
to fill it out so that's why the
department is going to implement the
systems and the schools are going to
demonstrate that they're providing
adequate education through those systems
that the department is implementing so
those are really department so those
systems themselves are a Statewide
system so a school can't Implement a
Statewide assistant the department has
to do that and the school participates
in a small piece of it which becomes a
Statewide accountability system thank
you
are those rules adopted by the State
um
I'll set 14 rules right here
so Ouija um we we got rid of that in the
rule reference and just referred back to
page 12 the list again page 12 or 17. uh
17 yeah 12 is definitions that was one
of the places where the list existed in
okay so on on page 22 Rick uh
what what are we referring to by
requirements of paragraphs one and two
so that's the next set it's page 23
you'll see paragraph one
and that's the ibass system oh okay and
Page 24 starts paragraph two and that's
pbas
okay and um before I get down to
questions on that then and and this is
in a new section 193 e colon 4.
yeah so these sections traditionally had
lived within 183h previously
um and half well half of it lived in 183
e half of it lived in 183h right and we
were running into problems where people
would read 193e and think that was the
whole accountability system and not
realize there was the other half an h
and vice versa people look at H and not
realize the first half was an e so this
was our attempt to take the two halves
ibass and P bass and put them into the
same section of law so you could
actually read them consecutively because
you have to do both okay and so did the
did the subsequent changes to the
oversight committee that we were talking
about reflect the changes from H and E
yes okay yeah so they have the same
oversight and now the oversight of the
system is all together in a single place
okay okay and then what's happening to
I think that's the oversight committee
no
[Music]
I'm on page 562. I was at the unique
people yeah identifiers we moved that to
a new section okay yeah all right starts
and I mean that's a very very important
section of law but it's not necessarily
specific to an adequate education right
it's it's more operational for the
Department it's just another thing right
yeah yeah and who knows why it ended up
nice yes good good with questions
sort of good questions why is knee s
breaking out uh credit accreditation
taken out
so the ibass system looks to see if
schools are compliant with that list of
of 12 or 13 things in the content of an
adequate education the ask accreditation
is something entirely different there's
a cost base to it so schools have to pay
for it so you we created a system by
which we were requiring schools to
demonstrate compliance with a set of
statutes or they could instead of
demonstrate a compliance do a niask
accreditation which does not look at New
Hampshire statutes and compliance so
it's not the same system and it created
a situation where schools that had more
resources could pay for the ask
accreditation and do it which is a valid
and rigorous accreditation process but
it sort of got them out of ibass where
the other schools were doing ibas and
they just weren't equivalent systems so
we were we there's a value to Nest
accreditation schools can go through and
do that on their own but there's no
requirement that schools in the state do
a knee ask specific accreditation it's
so
shall submit a narrative explanation
detailing how schools haven't compiled
each other we've taken that out too no
so that that remained so that that is
what ibas is so schools are required to
submit a narrative response of how
they're meeting each of those areas
identified in the content for an
adequate education
in the previous system if a school was
accredited through the ask they didn't
well the other thing there was
differences in times when you asked
accreditation I believe is every 10
every 10 years whereas the ibass
requirement was every two years so you
so schools that weren't doing the ask
had to do this every two years but if
you went through and paid for neaska
accreditation you could skip out on it
for 10 years so there's there's another
difference there haven't they changed
that I thought they went to five they
met I wasn't sure when I was in the
school system they're still doing 10
years but I I think there's some reports
which I do now much sooner than that
three yeah yeah I would have gone way
down yeah well it's a it's an update
with the highest rate of nothing you
don't have to do that and and so we just
what we wanted to be was we wanted to
have the same set of measurement across
all schools so I'm asked if I'm asking
the ask or similar kind of work I think
one replacing the other actually makes
sense but because it is not at all it
doesn't make sense to use them
interchangeably and so we said let's use
the same standards which is ibass and
ibass I mean anybody who has completed
it in the past specifically
representative cascadden
um knows the survey in the past was
pages and pages and pages long and there
was a lot of information that was in
there that wasn't necessarily related to
this area
um and so what the department has done
is we've gone through and we've said all
right let's make ibass truly what the
law gives us the authority to implement
and not ask all of these other questions
um and pair that down that survey and it
will anticipate it being a much
easier ask on the schools to implement
this new ibass system rather than go
through the fullness which has nothing
to do with an adequate education
you know years ago that's what we did ni
asked was how schools reported to
Department of Education right here in
Concord
um you know and of course I served on
the northwest Association schools and
colleges and there's a lot to this when
you're doing your self-evaluation you
involve your parents your community the
students the staff everybody and it's a
it's a healthy process in which you get
in you look at what you're doing and
then you invite a team to come in and do
that evaluation of your product
I cannot understand why we want to get
rid of it I I we don't want to feel it's
just another option all our high schools
except maybe one or two are knee ask
approved
so we and we don't want to get rid of it
we would like schools to get well we
like schools have the opportunity to go
through and ask if they want it's just
not a measurement of a school is
providing an adequate education or not
as defined by the state law and that was
our reasoning for getting rid of it
when you have it all those folks I just
mentioned contributing to it I think
you're going to get a even a better
report than you're going to get out
ibass well part of the problem is the
questions aren't the same and the
questions in ibas are directly related
to the school approval minimum standards
they say are you compliant with these
sections required in law niast doesn't
ask that so niac is doing a very
rigorous program evaluation of what the
school is offering but if you haven't
asked accreditation we don't know if
that means you're compliant with the
minimum standards or not it might mean
you have a very rigorous Academic
Program
but it's it's a different set of
questions that doesn't say yes or no are
you compliant with the content for an
adequate education and that's what this
section is supposed to do
we being the department or Nate no Us in
case and so and we had discussions with
the superintendents Association about
that as well and and
we probably spent about half an hour I
think just on the topic of the value of
niask accreditations should it be in
this section will schools continue to do
it because it does have value far beyond
this I don't think that whether it's a
substitute for IMS or not doesn't take
away any of the value of the nearest
accreditation and many schools will
continue to do that
I think the thing too is historically
this used to be part be part of
accountability for an adequate education
but that was previously that was before
we had ibas and pbas being required of
all schools so even so what we're trying
to say is we want to use the same
measurement for all schools across the
board but Force like all right some
schools were Neha schools some schools
were eyeball School some schools are P
bass schools and there's different
measurements but now you have changed in
2019 saying the measurement for
providing adequate education is a better
school is participating in ibass and P
bass so all right we have the same
measurement across the board so let's
not add this kind of third one of of me
ask in there and we can still encourage
and support schools going through the
niask process but it's accreditation is
not necessarily
indicator providing an adequate
education
so that was our pet saving if you want
to put it back in you certainly can
but
we just did it we didn't feel that it
a big Arrow by that one from left to
right
okay
um
anything else on that page
so did um did we have the the does the
performance-based accountability exist
in current law yes okay and and was it
in current law is it as distinct as
you're you're making it here we haven't
changed it okay
that's what had been an h and so we
simply took right and brought it in yeah
and and now putting it under 193 e
uh
in the adequacy
yeah and and I think the so
previously they read separately and
that's where we are ending up with
everybody being confused and they're
calling us and like well why do I have
to do PBS I can pass ibas and like whoa
because it says and and you have to read
them together and it made sense
historically that they were separated
because they were completely independent
systems in the past but when we changed
the or to an and that's where it really
needed to be read together I'm sorry I'm
sorry you've been no you said this like
three or four times
yeah this is what we're doing this is
this is what we've been doing and no and
it's because we've got a million calls
about this and and people are confused
and we're confused and the number of
times that Nate has corrected me when
I've said it incorrectly or vice versa
it's it's very confusing
but
why did you change the the visitations
to the schools as a May instead of a
shell wow
the department does not have any staff
to do this the department has not had
any staff to do this for a very long
time if you want the department to do it
and you want to keep it a shell we just
need a team of people to do this work
but we are not doing it we haven't done
it for a very long time yeah we have no
problem with doing the work but we
well let me ask you because the schools
have to pay for it and it's very
expensive
when you apply for currency are you
I'll get off it what
it is optional
that's good at three o'clock we're gonna
go to three o'clock because we did have
so
so you will make it a shell if you can
get more money huh of course
well could you use the me ask report as
your
site visit for those schools that do me
ask and then have a
Core group that you contract with you
know like retired superintendents that
would go out and do the same thing with
a team like me ask you know you have a
teacher on a team it still costs money
though I mean
whatever you want that system to be like
we can certainly build up this morning
um and I think that's more of kind of a
parking lot decision of like what do we
want it to be versus what does the
current law have
um because when we're having a
conversation with the superintendents
they had lots of great ideas of how to
make this a much better system but we
said let's come back to that next year
let's make the current system that we
have right now make sense so we can read
it together and then we'll talk about
maybe introducing some legislation and
working together and saying what let's
codify these great ideas that you have
to actually improve the system so that's
step two step one is figure out what
we're supposed to be doing right now
right
you you've mentioned throughout this uh
review several times about working with
the superintendent now could you explain
to us exactly how much time have the
superintendents you've worked with the
superintendents on this particular piece
of legislation how much time have you
spent with them yeah so we
um we have we first we started out with
a smaller group of superintendent
representatives and School Board
Representatives that came into the
department and met with us for several
hours
um and then we had a committee of about
10 or 15 superintendents come to the
department and they spent an entire
afternoon with us we went through this
line by line like this I do wish we had
this this document because it would have
been helpful
um but uh we did this and and and they
had lots of great suggestions comments
feedback
um and then we then met with a group of
about 20 additional superintendents in
January whenever that was
um and went over this with them again
um and so and Jerry fruit was actually
at the Senate meeting
um
when this was presented to the Senate
and he he testified that he supported
this bill and thanked the department for
the support and the work that we've done
with them to collaborate on this project
so
okay are there any further questions I
think we're getting down to the point
where we're running on Steam here
um while we're while we're on this yeah
this part on reporting yeah bottom of
25. yeah
um
so it so in reading this the the
currently the annual the annual
reporting is just based on the
performance um uh accountability and so
the new reporting will be on both input
and Performance Based
yeah so we've reported on both they just
existed separately so because we are
putting them together in the same
section of Statute we tried to put all
the reporting pieces together okay what
um if you were to if you were to take
the the input and performance space for
porting and then make a determination
down in the the uh the bottom of the new
language uh uh identifying all schools
that have failed to demonstrate the
opportunity for an education based on
those two factors
um would um would that report would
those identified schools be any
different than schools that are being
identified now
so it that will be the list so the
schools are identified as CSI TSI
schools that's the performance-based
accountability system so it would
essentially be an identical list
except that the state accountability
applies the rules to all schools while
our current federal list only applies to
Title One schools so you would see the
list expand from justice state
accountability perspective because we
would be looking at all schools
regardless of Title One funding
and the other thing is so the
performance phase is tied to the federal
accountability system right now the I've
asked us if somebody were to actually
fail ibass I guess they would be they
would also be consumed considered not
providing an adequate education so we
have not published an ibass list or a
failed ibass list and
I don't know 20 years so so like a what
like an ibass list would be based on
that the earlier list on the page
22 there's a version of it right right
of all the things so World Language is
one of those things so how would a
district like Pittsfield
um fare on the world language
front so it would depend on the school
level
um so there are not required standards
for World languages the elementary right
there is the option to have a world
language program at the middle school
and if a middle school chooses to do
that there are standards they have to
meet so one question would be do you
offer it at the middle school level if
so are you compliant with these required
areas and then at the high school levels
you know you are required to have a
world languages program you have to have
a certain number of course offerings in
your program of studies you have to have
at least two distinct separate languages
that are being offered and then there's
some standards that go along with that
so from a compliance perspective we
would be looking to see do you meet each
of those minimum standards under the
world languages program so that would be
that would be a new
um
even though the input
accountability exists now the report
would be considering those those Meeting
those inputs uh where in the past it
hadn't so so
this is pretty material for schools I
think it's so schools used to do that
and there would have been a report
involved we haven't done it a number of
years because we've had the staff to be
able to do the the ibass and the
reporting and the current form that it
had been previously was a really long
checklist if you look at all those
minimum standards underwater languages
you would have had about 40 or 50 items
and schools would check yes or no are
you compliant yes are you not no
and I would imagine some schools are
just going through and checking yes
because it was simply a yes and no
checklist that we would collect the
information but I don't think there was
a lot of reporting being done because
that really was what the school visits
were about because you would go out with
a team and you might have a world
languages expert on that team to go out
and say okay let me take a look at your
world languages program is it compliant
with these standards you've indicated in
your survey to us that it is and I think
that's to Caitlyn's point where she's
getting at is to really go out and do
those in-depth site surveys you know at
the very least you're going to want some
people experienced with math and Ela and
science to look at those programs and
and verify those responses on the ibass
okay okay great thank you Nate thank you
okay we're right at three o'clock and I
think we ought to call it right here so
we're at the bottom page 25
and then we got to get the stuff you
yeah of that and don't worry Jen's on it
she is
um
so we have another meeting scheduled for
this starting at 11 30 on Wednesday
it'll be the afternoon
so as soon as we finish executing on
Wednesday we'd start hammering away on
this again
hopefully we can plow through it
any any questions or
something good for the order
it's nope
okay thank you very much Caitlin and
Nate for coming here and all those that
came with them sending through this
thank you we appreciate the opportunity
to have this discussion with the
we actually we did have these
discussions both on it
we at the time when we asked
representative Ward to sponsor the bill
for us we sat down with it and went line
by line it was a several hour-long
meeting
[Music]
um this one where I had him as as the
um
foreign
um further into the issue
the
the amended bill
um
that are you familiar with the amended
the amendment that Senator Ward
submitted to us
language
Senator Waters yes
um
yes
written parental concern consent yes
um
go over what the intention is a little
bit
um social media is uh quite a a broad
terminology
um and
uh I've I've done research over the past
few years on digital badging and
credentialing and have more questions on
that and I'm not sure how that
specifically fits into
um what the goal is here sure absolutely
happy to address that so uh really the
purpose or the intent is to allow
students to be able to use some very
specific kinds of social media accounts
while they're in um in high school
particularly without naming names uh but
I will uh LinkedIn the idea being that
that's a way to authentically
um curate and to to have
um a record of Competency skills things
that that they could do for employment
which also persists after after high
school so it's there are um a number of
platforms that are really designed to be
used in education that are
um something that when the student
graduates doesn't travel with them but
something like LinkedIn is very portable
so employers
um
we'll look at it and it's something
where the student can say as a result of
my
um
work experience and educational
experiences I can do this this this and
this so again really it's it it's not
narrowly naming uh LinkedIn specifically
but that really is sort of the intent is
to use LinkedIn or other platforms that
emerge that have a similar
yes representative thank you for being
here
um my only concern really my primary
concern is with safety because there's
nothing in the bill as amended by the
Senate that would say it has to be an
app designed for education and there
could be other applications maybe for
other purposes that student could use in
a manner that's unsafe so I'm just
curious how you think we should address
something like that that is a really
good point
um I I think because the intent is for
curating Career Development
um
evidence I think that that if it were to
be a minute of language that would
address that specific usage I think that
would help provide some some clarity and
that could be something that I would
think could come out in administrative
rules
um as with the amendment this was my
first time drafting an amendment so I am
willing to play around with the wording
as the subcommittee sees fit but again
my goal is just to ensure safety in
terms of something like this would be
implemented I think from my perspective
I think that absolutely addresses that
concern
um if I may could I read the amendment
out I've brought with me a couple folks
okay
and the reason um that we had them come
along is that um yeah thank you and I'll
let them introduce themselves in a
moment um they'll have some um some good
input about the some of the security
concerns as they they are approached in
districts but um representative if I may
this definition shall not apply to
platforms used for demonstrating
evidence in student Career Development
nothing in this section shall encourage
student involvement in careers as
influencers social media models internet
personalities or otherwise diminished
student safety which again from my
perspective I think addresses those
concerns nicely it could be fleshed out
a little bit more with some clarity in
if I'm Pam McLeod I'm the director of
technology in the information security
officer in Concord here in the school
district and this is Josh Olstead he's
from Oyster River Cooperative school
district and we have been since HB 1612
which I know some of you were really
instrumental in we have been we've
founded and have been organizing our
response to that bill so we've created a
student data privacy Consortium
which currently includes about 130
000 students across New Hampshire and
protects data privacy we've managed to
get about 1300 different online
applications with data privacy
agreements since
2019. so we're pretty well versed in um
in that side of things I know that's a
different RSA but
foreign
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here to take these questions
um I did a fair bit of research to try
to understand the the real intent and
what's going on with the bill and we had
some concerns that we previously
discussed about things
what I found and I want you to tell me
if this is roughly accurate is the is
the platform LinkedIn once you get an
account and this is a business
networking platform primarily it's used
primarily to get jobs in the network
um once you're on that you can take
quizzes on any number of varied subject
matter in order to as they put it
demonstrate a competency and achieve a
digital badge that you can place then on
your profile to advertise that you have
a competency in this is that is that
roughly what we're looking to do yes yes
if I may follow up on that
um
so there's nothing there because the the
test there the quiz would be taken by
the student based on the knowledge that
they've already attained in school so
there's really nothing that would
prevent them from being able to do this
to achieve this competency of these
badges outside of school on their own
correct correct okay and one last
follow-up I think to get to the heart of
a little bit is sure certainly data
privacy is a concern but it's not
actually my foremost concern my biggest
concern here is
what happens when we create a sort of
Industry standard across the state where
students are doing this on social media
and using that to find jobs
for out straight straight from high
school and in high school and they're
now being subjected to the third party
terms of service of the social media
platform that is going to significantly
dictate their ability to get a job and
possibly represent a significant
constraint on things like their freedom
hmm
I'm not sure about that I agree with you
the terms the terms of service of the
platform absolutely apply and we looked
at LinkedIn it's age 16. so
um there is no way to bypass those terms
of service unless you have a data
privacy agreement with the company
LinkedIn is owned by Microsoft I think
there is hope that someday they will
have a high school
version of the platform
um I think a concern would be
um there's an instant messaging part of
the platform so just like any other
social media there could be instant
messaging between adults and students
that the school district would not be
pervy purview to but they could create
that with their own personal accounts
and that would happen there as well
could happen
if I may just one more to clarify just a
little bit of my concern so my concern
really centers around their terms of
service when it comes to things like for
instance they have something called a
hate speech policy now of course none of
us like you know hearing terrible
bigoted things and stuff like that
however the US Constitution does not
have a hate speech policy it's it's free
speech and by by putting students on
this platform for a job purpose they're
now going to be subject to third-party
hate speech guidelines that a student
could say something dumb at some point
and students do
and all of a sudden their job prospects
are potentially ruined as a result of
that is that a concern that we should
have yeah
I agree with you
um I I feel like it's part of our
certainly in schools and I think this is
a lot of what schools try to do is um
they try to help guide students into
professional tone of voice professional
you know your public your digital
footprint right
um in a sort of a guided way so that
students don't graduate and then go out
and make those mistakes you know if if
the idea being that if a teacher is
guiding them they're less likely to run
afoul of those particular policies but
yeah they're absolutely subject to the
terms of the platform
yep
that exist in in Industry right now and
that are still developing that are
specifically badging
and they do
a better job of privacy
Etc as well as verifying the badges and
all of that kind of stuff is there a
reason why we're not pursuing that
rather than
LinkedIn which is more risky for the
students well I think it's a yes and the
thing I do most uh most often is the
state director for Career Technical
education and the types of Industry
recognized credentials and badges that
you described are absolutely something
that the Career Technical lead programs
are encouraging and are helping students
to attain I think that that LinkedIn I
only mention it because it's something
that's fairly widely used but the intent
is not to have it be limited to LinkedIn
but rather to to limit it to things
where students can curate and collect
and then share evidence of Readiness for
employment so it's it's not something
that says this is the LinkedIn act but
rather this is the career development
exploration conferencing curation
Act
so then they will if a school decided to
um
use one of these other
they could do that would that would
um
sorry lime brain not working
um this would apply to those as well yes
so
[Music]
um would a school or a CTE Center for
instance pick out an app
like LinkedIn or another that they
wanted to use for their
students in that Center is that
how you see it working yes okay
um because I I don't have as much
confidence as representative lakis in
some of the digital badging systems
um
with LinkedIn
going through this questionnaire and
developing their competency
for publication on LinkedIn
would other
s be able to provide a quote certificate
or badge on LinkedIn or any of these
other sites I'm just wondering who is
going to have access to this besides the
student
a little bit more sure
um I think with some badging systems
credentialing systems
um a third party could say
um
uh the the student it could be for an
outside program has earned a credential
of such and such and posts that in that
badging system
um one of the security concerns I've
seen
um
is uh who are authorized users who you
know uh it's in if third parties are
allowed to post into the system
um it's possible that they might post
something that
um is not favorable
to the student
um and that's one of you know my
concerns I'm not sure in LinkedIn that
there's any ability for anybody else to
see anything I think the student would
either have to be connected to the
teacher for assessment to occur of the
project right either the student is
posting sort of privately and but
they're connected to the teacher so the
teacher can see their posts or the
student is posting publicly and then
anybody can see what's posted and what
what skills they've achieved but there
are certainly other industry credentials
which we wouldn't call social media and
I think that's some of the confusion
here is okay is there's other I'll give
you an example so we have a CTE Center
in Concord right um and we have not run
into any application that we have not
been able to obtain a data privacy
agreement for under
um HB 1612 which we all call it Center
different RSA right she's dead it was
[Music]
yeah 68a possibly 66 66 okay because I I
had concerns about the
68a which is the student online personal
information yeah statute also
um so uh for example we had a teacher
asked me for uh welding credentials so
it's an adult oriented
um you know it's a career oriented
credential
um and uh we didn't have a data privacy
agreement but I reached out to the
company so many states are jumping on
board now I had a DPA within two weeks
with that company so we really have
found that really just sort of doing the
legwork and digging in and trying to get
a data privacy agreement is our
preferred first step and it has worked
you know over 1300 times so this is
getting easier and easier to do
um a platform
like LinkedIn
um
this particular RSA because LinkedIn is
social media and this RSA is mostly
about social media investigations right
and protecting students privacy so
there's some mixing and um
I would caution to be um to avoid
confusion between the data privacy RSA
and the social media RSA because they
really have two different purposes so
just from the school district's
perspective I think there could be
confusion if you have to look into two
different rsas to think about data
privacy agreements you know data privacy
yesterday
um you mentioned you know going the
other beyond the LinkedIn I know in
testimony we heard about Adobe that has
not that's just a tool right that's
you're correct but is that one data
privacy agreement with on Adobe
um we do not have a data privacy
agreement with Adobe there's a handful
of very large companies that will not
give us data privacy agreements but we
use the security standards so as as part
of the law the state department of
education has developed security
standards by which we need to evaluate
so the law doesn't say we have to have a
data privacy agreement the law says that
the the companies the vendors need to
meet these security standards we have
evaluated Adobe and Google is another
one there's no data privacy agreement
with Google either we do have one with
Microsoft
um
that so we have evaluated those products
against the security standards and they
hold enough industry security standards
for example the Department of Defense
uses Adobe
um you know we have enough evidence that
they're fairly secure to feel pretty
confident in using them thanks thank you
it was interesting
um
189 68a the student online personal
information when I put that bill forward
Microsoft supported the legislation but
there was a Consortium
including Google opposed to the
legislation so it was yeah it was quite
interesting
uh representative Lucas
yeah um
thank you
do we need to be using social media
for badging when we have those industry
um
whatever you want to call application
um that will do that
that it's a completely you know it's not
social media and do we actually need to
be using social media or can we just be
using those other things which doesn't
even need this at all because it's not
social media it's an excellent question
I I think um and this is where I would
defer to pan because they but my take is
that as someone who works in career
development I see increasingly uh
resumes going in increasingly in the
electronic uh form where there's a
little bit of a hybrid right now where
someone will email a a resume as an
attachment but I suppose my concern
would be does that limit the reach of a
um a young job Seeker if curating
um experience is is happening more on
these sorts of platforms but I would I
would defer to Pam for the rest of the
answer I would say we're talking about
two different purposes there there is a
credentialing badging purpose
um students who receive a credential in
automotive technology or welding right
and and by the way we still do get
parent permission for those because
there's usually a fee involved in all of
that
um then there's the sort of how you
teach students how to go look for jobs
so that's you know I think where
LinkedIn falls into the bucket of we're
going to teach them how to use the most
prevalent social media platform which
people are actively using to go out and
find jobs and how to navigate that I
think those are skills they want to
teach the students
um
uh you know so I really think there are
two different
um two different buckets and it is what
makes it so confusing in terms of the
data privacy laws how we how we treat
um social media like LinkedIn
thank you and then my other question I
don't know if you saw the amendment by
Senator Waters which talks about
um clear career exploration or or CTE
um
using technology platforms and whatever
and having parental
but that's not social media either yeah
so
we don't actually need that Amendment
right because
Jewish and I have a strong opinion about
that um I think we've since we've done a
lot of work with the uh groups that
developed the original
um Bill and um that makes some sense I
think it was just a one sentence um bill
but um the amendment I think is where it
introduces a lot of confusion between
the data Privacy Law it's not
necessarily about social media
personally I feel I feel I think Josh
agrees that it's in the wrong place
um we would be more than happy to work
with the Department of Ed and and
um whoever would like to sponsor an
amendment next year to really look at
you know I agree that when it comes to
CTE programs there might be some
exceptions we need to make in the data
Privacy Law but wouldn't it be nice if
those exceptions were in the data
privacy RSA not the social media right
because it's not social media
um we've been doing leg work if we hear
of a particular tool that in any any CTE
program has not been approved
um we'll jump in and do some leg work
we've been calling companies we've been
doing everything we can to try to help
push those through the reality is local
control
I can't tell an I.T director in another
District how to run their District right
or what risk they're willing to assume
for their students
so we have some that are more
restrictive than I might be I'll go get
prayer permission for some tools but I
think that um I think that data privacy
laws are pretty good as they are now I
think we need to work out some we've
offered Jeff our help we need to work
out some specific products and see what
we can do but
um I'm not sure that that amendment is a
great fit in the social media right
because it's not social media so I'd be
willing to work with you on that for
yes but what about this year
you know uh I mean are we it's not
against the lawn yeah yeah
it's not covered under the social media
uh law at all
because it's not social media
I think the original our the original
bill was one sentence correct
estimate
yeah so we don't know
right
law and at the Second Step this
definition shall not apply to platform
reviews for demonstrating evidence in
yes Revenge Belcher
makes sense
thank you Mr chair I just want to drill
down a little deeper on the exact nature
of these certifications that are
available and and whatnot because I
think that'll help clarify things with
people a little bit
um and let's use Adobe as an example so
when a student in school goes through a
period of instruction in Adobe
if I'm not mistaken he is he or she is
then able to take through Adobe at their
school various testing to obtain a
certification in that adobe platform yes
and then that that is the if I'm not
mistaken the industry standard for that
is the certification direct from Adobe
there may or may not be badging
available for that right now I'm not
sure I if there's not there probably
will be
but when it comes to LinkedIn and I
don't mean to keep picking on LinkedIn
but they're like the big one right now
and they've got this all put together
it's just it's just it's just quizzes
that you take so it's not it's not a
industry standard certification it's
just a a brief example that lets them a
potential employer know that maybe you
know something and I say maybe because
in my research I saw lots of examples of
people using AI chat GPT to actually
fit these tests yeah you're right I I
just took a bunch of those quizzes for
fun the other weekend and you know I'd
take a cyber security quiz it was 15
questions I'd go through it I passed but
it's not the same as going out and
getting the industry standard where I go
to Pearson Testing Center and get the
actual you know credentials so they're
pretty light yes and just a brief I'm
sorry if I may there's nothing in
current law that would prohibit or make
it difficult for students to obtain the
industry standard Adobe certification in
school right now we approached that with
um we do ask for parent permission
usually a fee is involved and so you
know we sort of approach it that way
make sure the parents are on board thank
you um you know there's a number of
so in the example you just gave in that
credential for the cyber security
would was the company Pearson you
mentioned well Pearson runs the testing
center oh it could be like a cissp would
be one certification yes right would a
student be able to add that
certification to their LinkedIn account
to their profile they yes they can just
write it in yes okay yeah right yeah
um
would the student control who has access
to view their LinkedIn account
yes
yes and as as with most social media you
can connect with people and you can
decide whether your posts are viewable
by the people you're connected to or
whether they're public posts okay
so that would be the connection to the
teacher you mentioned yeah so it's kind
of a weird
um is you can look it up two ways one is
if they're connected to the teacher that
might not be desirable because they're
connected to the teacher then they can
instant message the teacher Etc
um however
um you may not want their post to be
public they could easily make a mistake
that could haunt them for their whole
careers or it could be a good thing kind
of want to guide them in that so
um
we we've been talking a lot about that
and I think I would prefer that the
students make public posts so they're
not actually directly connected to the
teacher and then then at the end of the
course they're guided on how to make
their posts private how to move it from
a school email address to a personal
financially for the account or a school
email address
that's a decision Point we've we've
determined we've been talking with our
attorneys that work with us we've
determined that if they use their
personal email address the way um RSA
18970 is written right now it would be a
personal social media account so that's
probably not desirable but if they use a
school email address then it's not a
personal social media account
um so that is sort of one point of
of contention we do want the kids to
take their profiles with them so we
would want them to leave school with it
under their personal account
you
change the account when they graduated
yes it's easy enough to do yeah
lives in Belgium thank you um so if it's
not if it's not a personal uh account if
it's a a school account
um and there are minor
what liability might the school have if
um that's an excellent point because we
don't have a data privacy agreement we
are completely bound
actually the student is completely Bound
by the terms of agreement with the
company
so there's a number of areas if you've
got a bright 15 year old student who
happens to be in junior level classes
with 17 year olds you can't allow them
to do LinkedIn because the terms of use
is 16. so anyway there's a number of of
areas where that might apply but the the
fact is you just have no control over
the terms of service the company
controls that and they could change at
any time
yeah so it does make us a little nervous
because there's sort of that lack of
most platforms that we use with kids and
you know Concord we have over 300
different tools that we use with kids
that are approved
we like to have some control over those
accounts
um for data privacy purposes if there's
a data breach we have certain laws that
nursing Hall thank you yeah yeah I'll
just take a note the a lot of stress on
this whole thing is on the teacher I
mean I taught technology for yeah for
many many years and
um
yeah you know what kids do but at some
point kids got to be able to do it and
that's the bottom line and you have to
but the teacher assumes a lot of
responsibility particularly if they're
young I mean I I did Adobe the whole
Adobe suite to middle schoolers and you
do have to watch what they're doing and
um but you can't stop them from doing it
you can stop them but you shouldn't stop
them right I guess what I want to say so
Josh I don't do a risk everything has a
risk and I think we can't be dinosaurs
yeah so yeah uh Josh wanted me to point
out that you know under FERPA which is
the primary Privacy Law that we operate
federally with
um we do schools have the right to
exercise the school official exception
and um you know obtain parent permission
for things like this if if we were to do
something like LinkedIn and a parent did
not opt into it and the student wasn't
18 we would have to find an alternative
foreign
that was something I had a question
about the alternatives for students who
don't participate would these students
be at a disadvantage if their classmates
get these industry credentials and are
able to advertise them on LinkedIn or
other platforms what about the other
classmates
that is always the case you strive for
equity and
um
I'm sure that there's other ways that
they can do it they could do like a
Google site or something but it's not
the same you're not connecting with
those industry partners
um and
you know the students can by law go out
and create their own LinkedIn accounts
too you know they don't need parent
permission even because the age of
consent is 13 right under Copa federally
um so
um kids can do it on their own it's just
I think the question is having the
school direct the kids to do it is a
um I think a lot of the schools
um in New Hampshire use a product called
I think it's PowerSchool yes
um and I think the parent company
and I'm not sure it's directly through
uh PowerSchool or another one of their
affiliate projects products does have a
credentialing or badging
capability to it
they have a lot of products yeah so they
probably do right yeah because that's
one I've seen mentioned in regard to
some of these safety concerns
um which would CTE centers be using
well let's say if the school X already
has power school would they be using the
CTE Center for that school would they be
using
uh product from the PowerSchool company
in addition
instead of LinkedIn possibly I I guess
it's possible
um the truth about that company's
products is they're very expensive so
not a lot of schools have a lot of the
other products in this week because they
have a lot there's probably 20 different
products that they offer I'm not sure of
the one that you're referring to but I
know that when we look at any of their
products we're looking at
very expensive products so we don't
necessarily purchase them I would say
too representative cordelli that my main
concern is I want to make sure that
students have something that's real
world and authentic and many of these uh
products that are designed to be used in
schools may not be recognized by
employers so that's something I always
want to keep front of mind is is this
something that truly is as for the Adobe
that had come up a couple times is the
industry standard and recognized by
potential employers right and that's
partially where some of my
original concerns came into play with
the student online personal information
RSA because it's designed for
products designed and marketed for K-12
purposes yes which so LinkedIn would not
fall underneath this
statute but a power school
um my I think that's that particular
designation has been a point of
confusion
um that might be worth clarifying in a
future year with some stronger language
because each district again sets their
own level of risk and so for some
districts it's just easier to say no
foreign
further questions
um
I thought I might
send you
um
maybe for your review
um I had a briefing paper that talked
about legal issues
with some of the FERPA and Copa Etc
maybe just for you to review and we
could
um you know get back together again and
maybe talk about
the original Bill and talks more about
representative McDonald's Amendment and
talk about a specific language
mm-hmm
this
anyone else have any comments for right
now yeah excellent yeah
good afternoon Jeff
um does Concord have in the school
district any policies in place
which are addressing currently what
we're trying to look at in legislation
right now social media policies
[Music]
um
yeah we do have so
RSA 18970 is really about protecting
students during investigations so yes we
would have a policy that is based off of
that
um in the district I'm not sure of the
exact number of the policy but most
districts do I'm also a school board
member in a different District so those
are policies that I have definitely seen
before yes
so
agreement that would have to be
um you're talking about General data
privacy
um yeah so part of the um the HB 1612
part of RSA 18966 is that we have a data
governance plan and so most districts
have developed those as policy
um in the districts and they really
outline what we do
um with all kinds of cyber security and
data governance but including vendor
products
um and how we approach those and each
district does it their own way
um but most districts in New Hampshire
have joined our Consortium or we call it
an alliance I think we have um 80 82
percent of districts in New Hampshire
um yeah under that Alliance so that
basically we're all doing the heavy
lifting for each other if I sign a data
privacy agreement with PowerSchool and
another District wants power school they
just sign a one-page addendum they don't
have to go through that whole
negotiation step
um so so that's how we've been so
successful in getting those data privacy
grants policy talking about also deal
with representative McDonald's issues of
safety
um
yes and no like we don't use any social
media officially in the district with
students we have very few exceptions
um
but um
I I
um the paragraph that she added here
um
yeah I don't I don't see any issues with
that at all
um I do think we have you know we have
to be aware of student safety issues
in terms of
privacy agreements absolutely and
there's a great um Concord monitor
monitor article last fall so I'll send
that to you she did a really nice job
explaining it it's a complicated process
but she did a really nice job with it so
great representative Paul
so Jeff the question for you so what is
it you need
to make things work let's say 60 days
after passage let's say if there was
something in the is it can is there
something you can't do now that you want
to be able to do in September
um well I I think the
um
the ability for a a teacher to lead a
group of students through creating
um
profiles portfolios that can then be
shared in real time and to be able to
guide them through here's how you use
these types of platforms I think that
this would enable that to to happen and
it can't happen right now
I get asked can I follow up I guess I'm
just thinking
to build on that like when I taught
middle school and the kids made
portfolios on websites they could share
or not share I mean I mean we're talking
about high school kids like I think we
do need to teach see let these kids do
this man I think we need to write it
however we need to write it to make it
work May I add that we've been working
with New Hampshire nhli New Hampshire
learning initiative recently because
they were working with Senator waters on
this language the initial proposed
language and I think we have found we've
been working with our attorneys and we
have found ways to use LinkedIn in
schools without legislation so and it
has to do with using their school email
accounts so it's not a personal social
media and getting parent permission so
everything that is in law right now
would allow us to do that without
running a foul of the way
um 189.70 reads right now so I I think
it's it's a matter of you know we did a
little digging in we talked to different
attorneys we have a data privacy
attorney that we work with in our
Consortium and and Josh and I actually
presented to their group uh was it just
last week maybe about how how they could
foreign
so do we then actually need this
legislation if they can do it as long as
they're using the school account and get
parental permission and all of that
stuff because this might open it up
Beyond using the you know that and that
seems like a good idea because it still
provides the opportunity for the kids to
learn and all of that without as much
risk
in my opinion no I think Jeff would
still like it to be there I think that
original introduced legislation at the
Senate which was just the one sentence
would help but um I don't think it's
necessary
um there was I don't think it's on this
piece of paper wasn't there a whole
paragraph amended about data privacy in
general
um during its
uh time in the Senate
so I think there's a whole nother
paragraph added I really think that that
would add a lot of confusion because it
should be under the do you want to see
so that was the original and this is the
new so the original was this definition
shall not apply to platforms used for
demonstrating evidence in student career
development
um and um
I think that's just fine but anything
else that really talks about data
privacy I think is in the wrong RSA
yeah paragraph two is the thing that I
think causes some confusion this is from
the perspective of being in the
technology director having to navigate
these laws and I think that this
paragraph would certainly be worth
looking at as part of the data privacy
189 66 next year but in the social media
ripsing Paul
um so what is the procedure let's say if
we wanted to not do the amendment which
has been brought to us but go back to
the original
one with that one sentence what is a
process there how does that go about can
you go about that or did you make
another amendment what do you have to do
right we could do another amendment that
goes back to the original
or whatever you can do whatever okay
whatever we want the Senate right yeah
committee conference yes that's what I
two questions one to each
um the amendment that Senator Waters
brought in for paragraph two
do you like the wording of that and if
we just could we put that but in the
proper part of law rather than social
media where it doesn't belong I mean
because if we're amending
we could just amend where it goes
if you think it's good the way it is
otherwise we'll take the time and do it
next year
um
we don't feel that it's necessary
because we can already do parental
opt-in uh permission under FERPA so we
already have that ability I think this
is aimed at the districts where maybe
they're taking a harder line than some
of us do
um but um
I um I do think that if we were going to
consider language like this we would
want it in 66 instead of 70.
so would that be appropriate I mean do
you have a problem with the way it's
worded if we just put it in 66 rather
than
the place it is no Josh he's more legal
than I am because yes it was
specifically aimed at districts who said
oh according to the rules we can't do it
and it's to make it clear that yeah you
can this is the process what what I
would like to do is because we just got
brought into this maybe about a month
ago Josh and I
um what I would like to do is spend
maybe six months really working on some
of these products with the Department of
Ed with the CTE directors let's see
where the barriers are and try to work
through the issues and then kind of go
fresh into next year and see what do we
need in the law because it does feel
like we're over legislating a little bit
thank you yeah when I read the law I
said this isn't necessary so and nhli is
has offered up some funds for us to help
them develop some guidance and some
guidelines we've started speaking to the
superintendents Association because in
my mind the only people that can mediate
between CTE directors and Technology
directors our superintendents so we've
started to really think about what can
we do more in terms of communication and
just really providing materials and sort
of flow charts and best practices that
might help alleviate some of these
situations I I think I'd rather more
than happy to work on legislation but I
think I'd rather try the Kinder gentler
approach okay thank you one option would
be to retain 213 and work on it into the
fall
um
give us some more time and your
conversations that you're you're having
with superintendents Etc have some more
time to come up with something a little
bit broader and
satisfies everyone's
concerns that that would be
an option and they worked really hard on
that introduced you know the bill as it
was introduced that one sentence I would
hate to say anything here that would
negate all of that hard work and that we
have no problem with that sentence
really I mean if if that's something you
wanted to move forward
um a lot of Educators have worked very
hard on that one particular sentence so
I have a follow-up meeting after some
consideration we have have some time and
we have a number of other meetings
scheduled in the upcoming weeks that we
could piggy back a follow-up meeting on
to
um
and take a look at that if
so would it be better to
move forward with this bill right here
with the one sentence
and then in November put forth a new
bill
I'm checking before I say something that
represents both of us all of us a new
bill would be
introduced in January and not signed
into law until next
summer
I think I'd prefer the one sentence in
in 213 and then and then um
and then kind of regrouping and seeing
what we need to do with data privacy
I'm all for that I think I misunderstood
what was just said when we went to
January that was a new bill is that what
you said yes a new bill would be
introduced in January if you move
forward with this one right right
the one sentence it would still be
January no that would be now I mean it
would be in the fall yeah if you move
forward with one sentence now it'd
probably be signed in oh yes right yes
right right okay that's what I mean yeah
it'll take another year exactly yeah I'm
all for now it's and it's my hope that
when we come back in six months we'll
have communicated all the issues out and
we just don't need to
if if we do an amendment with the one
sentence back to the original
um then
um if we pass it it will then require a
um
why don't we
take a little bit of time think about it
and have another brief meeting
um in in the near future and decide if
we want to go forward with the one
thank you thank you
great
okay
foreign